Jetzt geht's.
Jetzt probieren wir es nochmal.
Was? Alter.
Ich krieg Modern Warfare.
Was? Was? Was geht hier ab?
Was macht das Game mit meinem Rechner, ey?
Was macht das Game mit meinem Rechner?
Kann man das Game capture?
Ist das Game gecaptured?
Okay, vielleicht geht es mit Game capture besser.
Wir droppen Frames, oder?
Okay, wir probieren es jetzt mal aus.
Sagt mir, ob es ruckelt.
Bis jetzt ist es okay, ne?
Bis jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren.
Droppen auch nix.
Okay.
Kokona. Weiter geht's.
Call of Duty, ja.
Näh, tja.
Single Player.
Wir droppen nix.
Okay, wir droppen keine Frames.
Sehr gut.
Keine Frames rum. Wo muss ich hin?
Hier.
Ich bin voll falsch gelaufen.
Gut, also zurück zur Story.
Wir stelzen uns durch irgendeine verlassene russische Basis,
die wir vorher weggebasht haben.
Kann Pixel zählen?
Ich stream mit 6900 Bitrate.
Ist das echt so pixelig?
Keine Güte.
Also Call of Duty ist echt immer mega anstrengend zu streamen.
Ja, gut.
Das ist jetzt, weil es dunkel ist.
Ne, ich stream nicht mehr über Grafikkarte.
Ich stream wieder mit CPU.
Aber vielleicht liegt das an der Bitrate.
Vielleicht stelle ich es lieber wieder auf Very Fast.
Weiß jemand, ob man das on the fly umstellen kann?
In OBS und es funktioniert ohne Streamload zu starten?
Ich guck gerade mal auf meine Vorschau.
Naja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt wirklich viel besser ist.
Warum 48?
Ja, weil das Game laggt, wenn ich mit 60 FPS streame.
Okay, auf geht's.
Bei den dunklen Teilen, ja gut.
Dunkel ist immer so ein Wunderpunkt bei ganzen Streaminggeschichte.
Der Price hat die Grafik weggeraucht, ja.
Ich mein, 6.900 Kilogramm, also besser, mehr Quali geht eigentlich nicht.
Die nicht neu starten.
Ja, kann man jetzt mit leben oder nicht?
Ich mein, das in dunklen Bereichen ist Pixel, ist normal.
Das in dunklen Bereichen Pixel ist normal.
Wir warten mal, bis es hell wird.
Oh, jetzt kommt Nachtsichtgerätstelle.
Aber was geht, wir machen das erstmal.
Oh, jetzt ist ja wahrscheinlich voll abartig, ne?
Ich muss mir das jetzt mal in der Vorschau angucken, das pixelt wahrscheinlich wie Hölle jetzt.
Quatsch, so schlimm ist das doch gar nicht.
So vollkommen okay, wie das ausschaut.
Das sieht bei keinem Stream besser aus.
In solchen Szenen.
Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung, sieht das aus.
Ich seh's hier grad bei mir in der Vorschau.
Das sieht, das sieht richtig, das sieht sogar richtig gut aus.
Ah, oh, da hat's gestelzt.
Gleich mal rein sliden hier, bashen.
Ja, huge aim am Start.
Ah, wo, wo ist er?
Fuck.
Über mir.
Ach nee, entgegen jedem anderen Game ist ja in Call of Duty eh Nahkampf und F benutzen.
Ist ja was, Leute, das ändern wir jetzt gleich mal.
Das ändern wir jetzt gleich mal.
Ähm, ich wüsste nicht, wo.
Ach, hier.
Ähm, F-U's.
E-U's.
Und Nahkampf?
Nahkampf F.
Genau, so, passt.
Passt wohl.
Bin.
Ah, ich muss die Lichtschalter anmachen.
Licht kommt an.
Wir haben ein Problem.
Diese Leute sind eine russische Armee.
Spätznaz.
Spätznaz ist am Start.
Singleplayer Kek W.
Wo ist eigentlich Price am Start?
Price ist gar nicht dabei.
What?
Quickmuffs?
Oh, Achtung, bashen.
Nee, ich glaub, das sind unsere.
Ach, das sind unsere.
Okay, wo genau sind die jetzt hergekommen?
War blöde Frage.
Wie sind die hier reingekommen?
Das Tor ist abgeschlossen.
Moin, Eax.
Äh, ich muss mal grad mein Programm wieder starten, mit dem ich Bildchen einblenden kann.
Ähm, sonst kann ich nämlich nicht mal Kokona einblenden.
Äh, aber.
Wenn ich nicht Kokona einblenden kann, dann kann ich nicht mal Kokona einblenden.
Das ist fatal.
Vielleicht hat es wegen Anti-Cheat gelaggt, weil ich was im Hintergrund laufen hatte.
Meint ihr, das könnte sein?
Also Leute, wenn es jetzt wieder anfängt zu laggen, ne?
Dann liegt es an Anti-Cheat.
Wenn ich Kokona einblenden geht, dann ist alles gut.
Einsteigen.
Och nee.
Das macht Pause, wenn ich Kokona Einblendungen mache?
Nö.
Macht's nicht.
Autsch.
Nein, kein Raytracing, kein RTX On.
Ich hab hier nur eine 1080.
Nur, nur eine 1080 Ti.
Wir werden gebasht.
Geht aber nicht.
Was, ihr seht nichts? Warum seht ihr nichts?
Ja.
Nee, ich hab diesmal keine 2080 Ti gekriegt.
Danke für die ganzen Subs, Leute.
Den haben wir hier.
Next to Kai.
Moment, Leute.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz was zur Story sagen.
Leute, kann das sein?
Oh nee, Story, Story Time.
Muss jetzt ruhig sein.
Wir sind nicht Clearanced.
Oh, was jetzt?
Was jetzt?
Wow.
Whoa.
Fall of Duty, please.
Das ruckelt bei mir jetzt übrigens auch.
Okay, was ist denn von hier?
Massenvernichtungswaffen wieder am Start.
Was?
Was passiert überhaupt?
Sie haben bei den Russen
irgendwelches Massenvernichtungsgas
gefunden oder so.
Und Bryce basht die Leute.
Und jetzt sind wir in London.
Okay, ich blicke noch nicht so ganz durch,
aber das kommt vielleicht noch.
Er sieht irgendwie voll französisch aus, oder?
Ich finde, das sieht irgendwie
voll französisch aus, der Typ.
Und er auch.
Irgendwie sehen die voll französisch aus.
Ich kann es nicht beschreiben, warum,
aber irgendwie
schaut er nach Frankreich aus.
Und dabei sind wir in London.
Okay, die fahren da einfach so vorbei.
Big Brain.
Oh ne, was jetzt?
Okay, erstmal alles fest.
Okay, die Terrorists machen das,
was die Terrorists am besten können.
Eine Runde
Annele-Time.
Das ist auch schon so ein bisschen Klischee, oder?
So Terrorist am Start.
Oh nein, was ist? Bam! Erstmal sich in die Luft sprengen.
Es können Terroristen nichts anderes, als sich in die Luft sprengen.
Okay, man muss aber sagen,
im Verhältnis mit...
Wahrscheinlich können Terroristen wirklich viel anderes, als sich in die Luft sprengen.
Andere in die Luft sprengen.
Und deswegen, die Game wirklich so gut aus...
Das sieht relativ gut aus, ja.
Oh.
Oh, Uhre!
Das ist einer von mir.
Wow, da ist er.
Der Terrorist.
Wir brauchen eine ordentliche Waffe.
Oh, das war ein Polizist.
Oh, okay.
Suicide Bomber.
Silence.
Oh, meine Waffe ist leer.
Ich brauch...
Ammo.
Wo ist Ammo?
Hier.
Was?
Beste.
Fehlen nur noch die roten Tigerstreifen.
Dann kann nichts mehr schief gehen.
Rote Tigerstreifen.
Weg.
Oh!
Noch mehr Suicide Bombers.
Offices down.
Die Inszenierung ist cool.
Gefällt mir.
Wenn auch ein bisschen vorhersehbar alles, aber...
Okay.
Gucken wir uns mal ein bisschen um, ob sie sich Mühe gegeben haben.
Wir schauen uns mal an, ob sie sich Mühe gegeben haben.
Wir gucken uns mal ein bisschen um.
What the hell?
Was jetzt?
Warte mal.
Okay, ich dachte, die Mission geht im Haus weiter, aber gut.
Oh, eine AK.
Die...
Was?
Aha, hier geht's nicht weiter.
Okay, für Call of Duty-Verhältnisse sind das hier schon tatsächlich relativ offene...
Okay, hier haben wir das übliche.
Hier haben wir das übliche Call of Duty.
Sie verlassen das Schlachtfeld.
Das ist die falsche Flagge.
In Call of Duty ist prinzipiell eigentlich nur die US-Flagge erlaubt.
Für mehr Toner.
Es sieht aber gut aus.
Okay, wir gucken uns mal kurz um, wie das so ausschaut.
Hier?
Wahrscheinlich dürfen wir...
Nee, wir dürfen nicht in Häuser rein.
Das hätte mich jetzt gewundert.
Wir dürfen mit Sicherheit auch nicht drüber.
Okay.
Also hier sollen wir, glaube ich, lang.
Ich glaube schon.
Hier sollen wir lang, oder?
Okay.
Auf was schießt der da eigentlich?
Alles okay?
Sergeant Evans?
Alles gut?
Ich meine, ich kann verstehen, dass in London der Verkehr schon ein bisschen ätzend ist, ja?
Also ich habe ja gehört, dass diese Ringstraße, die London umgibt, so eines der schlimmsten Straßen sein soll auf der Welt.
Aber dass der jetzt die Ampel da irgendwie wegbashen muss, weiß ich auch nicht.
War da oben ein Schneider?
War da ein Schneider-Dude drin?
Wow, da war ein Schneider.
War da ein Schneider drin?
Aha!
Warum du bei mir Sport-Ads bekommst, ja?
Weil E-Sport.
Kann man die Schüte runterschießen?
Das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren, ob man die Schüte...
Kann man nicht.
Ich will einfach mal gucken, ob die sich Mühe gegeben haben mit der Map, bevor wir mit der Mission weitermachen.
Einfach mal schauen.
Excellent.
Five-Hand-Musik.
Wein.
Der ist da schön gescriptet.
Spawn.
My kind of music.
Genau.
Exquisite.
Okay, machen wir die Mission weiter.
Also, für Call of Duty-Verhältnis ist das ja hier schon eigentlich eine Riesen-Map, ne?
Und architekturtechnisch ist es auch ganz gut.
Ganz nett, ja.
Kann man Lampen kaputt machen?
Haben sie nicht irgendwo im Trailer gezeigt, man kann...
Man kann Lampen kaputt machen?
Okay, auf geht's.
Ich mache die Mission mal weiter.
Erstmal Track-Moven.
Oh.
Gang.
Da ist er.
Der Price ist heiß.
Der Pausbacken-Price.
Ach komm, Price.
Der ist ein bisschen schneller um die Ecke.
Oh, guck mal, der hat einen.
Ich...
Ich würde es ja mal gerne probieren, was passiert, wenn ich da drauf schieße.
Wir probieren das mal kurz.
Okay, es explodiert tatsächlich.
Es explodiert tatsächlich.
Da haben sie drauf geachtet.
Übrigens, danke für die ganzen Subs.
Also, was haben wir denn jetzt alles gekriegt?
Äh, Headpin, Nexo, KK, Ultimate Power, Twitcher, Tommy Lee,
We have a man with a bomb strapped to him.
Keep your distance.
Sergeant, over here now.
Oh, ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt Bomb-Defuse machen.
Fresh, so 0.
Dankeschön.
Okay, ich darf keine Twitch Prime-Ansagen machen.
Okay, Leute, gleich.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal Story weitermachen, ja?
Fresh, so Independent Astoria.
Dankeschön, Twitch Prime.
Tut.
We have a man with a bomb strapped to him.
Keep your distance.
I don't want to die me.
Can you help?
Let me see my car.
It's going off.
You can't get it.
No time!
All stations, bomb is clear.
Prone medical, we're coming up.
Everybody stay calm.
We're gonna get you out of here.
You're broken?
I'm good.
Let's go.
Inszeniert ist das echt nice
Kann ich nix sagen
Aber, ich mein
Er hätte auch einfach das Handy abreißen können, ne
Weil er hätte das Ding kein Zünder mehr gehabt
Ja, das wär zu
Big Brain gewesen, glaub ich
Bin ich das?
Bin ich?
Oh, man sieht mal, wie man aussieht, das ist doch gut
Alex Hunter
Genau
Okay, also sie sind angepisst
Weil sie nicht
Nicht machen können, was sie wollen
Ich seh keinen Mauszeiger
In der Kassierung
Wo hat's Hekistan?
Duh
Kein Terrorist hat noch ein Schiff von russischem Gas gekauft.
Nur Al-Qahtala würde das tun.
Die Russen machen keine Unterschiede zwischen Al-Qahtala und deinen Leuten.
Und ich mache keine Unterschiede zwischen Al-Qahtala und der russischen Armee.
Sie sind beide Terroristen.
Wir würden diese Pfeifen niemals benutzen.
Dann helfe uns, sie zu retten.
Natürlich, das würden wir nie machen.
Wir nehmen sie nach Europa? Oder nach Amerika?
Wir leben täglich so.
Kommande, es ist Zeit zu gehen.
Wo ist das?
Alex, das ist mein Bruder und Lieutenant, Hadir.
Du bist CIA?
Er arbeitet mit Kapitän Price.
Dann tötest du die Russen, ja?
Ich habe Freunde, die uns helfen können.
Aber deine Schwester hat entschieden, was sie will.
Natürlich. Meine Schwester ist in Kommande.
Und die russische Armee ist immer noch hier.
Diese Angelegenheit muss enden.
Darauf können wir uns alle einig sein, ja?
Nein.
General Barcels Männer kontrollieren die Stadt.
Wir haben Pläne.
Wir müssen das ändern.
Wir haben keine Missile, aber wir haben unsere Wege.
Wenn du bleibst, können wir dir helfen.
Aber wenn du bleibst, kämpfst du.
Die L&R-Truppe...
...liegt in der Nähe.
Folgt mir.
Gibt's das?
Gibt es Ur-Zikistan?
Diese Tunnels sind unsere Leitlinie.
Wir haben intelrussische Truppenkommandanten in der Stadt heute.
Wir werden sie besiegen.
Ach, mir fällt jetzt auf, was die Fahra heißt.
Ich werde ihre Aufmerksamkeit bekommen.
Endliche Sicherheit entfernt von der russischen Basis.
Wir lassen sie offen zu einem Angriff.
Wir müssen nichts tun.
Wir sind zu weit auf diesem Weg.
Und wir verlieren uns selbst.
Bereit für den Angriff auf die Airbase.
Sei sicher.
Alex, nimm diese Anzeichen.
C4 mit remote detonator.
Danke.
Schau auf meine Schwester.
Viel Glück.
Du auch.
Wir müssen weiter.
So, jetzt fangen wir an.
Wenn ich, wenn ich jetzt zu sehr auf den Hintergrund gucke,
regen sich die...
welch, welch?
Kleine Instant Anzeige raus.
Ja.
Da regen sich die Feministen über das Game auf.
Das geht nicht.
Hör mal.
OK, ich soll mich verkleiden.
Auch gut.
Erstmal so eine schöne Terroristenmaske aufziehen.
Fresh.
It'll do.
Oh!
Fuck!
Ach, und dann...
Ohne...
Oh...
Oh, oh, oh, oh...
Guck mal...
Ich muss hier rüber.
Oh...
Oh, oh, oh...
Ich muss hier rüber.
The fuck, ich glaube, ich sollte nicht schießen, oder?
Ich glaube, ich sollte nicht schießen.
Kann das sein?
Na gut, zum Glück sind die Russen so blöd
und lassen sich bashen.
Okay, die Russen sacken.
Gib mal die AK her.
Okay, wir concealen.
Wir concealen das Weapon.
Jetzt ist Secret.
Also wir haben jetzt erstmal 10 Russen umgebracht,
aber jetzt wird Secret.
Das merkt bestimmt auch keiner mehr jetzt.
Nachdem ich erstmal 10 Stücke Geld habe.
Käfer, zeig mir, wo es lang geht.
Weiß jemand, ob das Game
irgendwelche Secrets im Singleplayer hat
in Form von Marken, die man sammeln muss,
Audiologs, die man sammeln kann,
Abzeichen, Waffen oder so?
Oder kann man einfach Main...
Okay, man kann einfach Main weg lang stellen.
Das ist Gott.
Männer auf der Arbeitsplatte,
Frauen in den Trucks.
Okay, keine so gute Idee.
Das geht ja nicht, ja.
Ich glaube, die Story möchte,
dass ich die nicht kille, oder?
Die Story möchte, dass ich hier
Steine nehme
und dann mit dem Stein hier langstelze.
Das hat jetzt keiner gemerkt,
dass sie den gerade
Ballistic knifed hat
across the map.
Geht ab.
Bäschen, ja.
In your face.
Only use me knife, Farah.
Und ich muss...
Moment, Moment.
Was für Knopf war Waffe verstecken?
Und ein Dual mit dem Friseur.
Der Friseur interessiert sich leider nicht mehr dafür.
Kaufen oder nicht, weiß ich noch nicht.
Ich habe gerade erst angefangen.
Ja, dasspecific sage ich jetzt nicht.
Kristin etwas justo.
Ach komm, wir brauchen keinen Suppressor.
Guck mal, das sind...
was sind das, da...
Wir brauchen noch keinen Suppressor.
Buckth, Mann, das sind die übelsten Kack Salvador.
Ach Gott!
Wow!
Okay, vielleicht sollte man uns da reinholen.
Okay, Suppressor.
Oil-Filter.
Nein, das ist nicht Veteran, das nicht.
Wutz.
nicht Veteran, das ist normal. Aber die
Story möchte nicht, dass ich hier schieße, deswegen bin ich
wahrscheinlich so schnell down.
Ähm, Eulfilter,
Eulfilter.
Ich kann kein Kyrillisch.
Ich bin in der Garage. Hier.
Filter.
Wie das passt,
hä? Wie das passt.
Da hat es sich doch endlich mal gelohnt,
die ganzen Live-Hack
Videos auf YouTube zu gucken.
Du willst MacGyver, ja.
Viel bloßes Taschenmesser.
Wahrscheinlich hat er Live-Hack, Top 10
Live-Hack, ähm.
Und da wird es bestimmt gezeigt,
wie das funktioniert.
Der ist schon tot, der musste nicht noch mehr killen.
Overkill.
Okay, ähm.
Wir haben eine AK-47, glaube das ist.
Oh, guck dir mal.
Das war die OP-Waffe. Wo ist die Waffe hin?
Das war doch eben eine, hier.
Das war die OP-Waffe aus MW3.
Schaut mal.
Kennt ihr die noch?
Das, das, das ist die übelste, das war diese krass OP-Waffe aus MW3.
Die Dildo-Gun, genau.
Das ist eine.
Clear.
This way.
Sorry about your contacts.
We have the explosives.
Your sacrifice will not be in vain.
Ach, zum Glück,
Glück.
Das liegt das hinterm Sofa versteckt.
Oh, ein Lifted.
Interessant, dass die Pistole
mit so einem
draufgeflatschten
Ölfilter auf einmal
den
Ultrasilencer drauf hatte.
Aber man muss halt kreativ sein.
Quasi wie bei der Sendung mit der...
Ne, ne, was war diese Bastelsendung?
Die Sendung mit der Maus war
Wir erklären euch, wie es ist.
Es gab doch
so eine Sendung, wo die immer gebastelt haben.
Warte mal!
Ja?
Es waren halt ein paar Leute erhängen.
Was ist das?
Bitte.
Sie kann gerade eine Zeit lang ansteigen.
Stells mich da mal vorbei.
Sie können sich weiterhin nicht verhindern.
Sie können sie nicht aufholen.
Sie haben anderes.
Das ist ein verdammter Kriegsgeschäft.
Ob man die Leute retten kann?
Für die entdeckten Gasreize.
Barkov beschuldigt uns um sie zu stehlen.
Was können wir tun?
Liedt ruhig auf.
Sollte die给ingerten Leute
einen Ende zu Barkovs Crualty played forever.
Das ist ein Story, es geht nicht, dass man die Leute retten kann.
Bist du ein Terrorist oder was?
Einige unsere Gründe gerne einstellen.
Ausweichen diese Terroristen.
Und du wirst erfreut.
Jetzt?
Also ich weiß, ich soll weiter.
Mal gucken, ob hier noch was passiert.
Wir schauen mal, wie sehr sie sich Mühe gegeben haben.
Der Dude, der kreiselt einfach nur weiter jetzt.
Da war kein Budget mehr für mehr Dialog da.
Budget fertig.
Nice.
Ne, ne, ich laufe nicht in die Mitte.
Wenn ich in die Mitte laufe, dann bashen die mich.
Auffahrer.
Ich mache das jetzt absichtlich.
Also mir ist klar, dass ich jetzt mit dem Fahrrad die Treppe hoch soll.
Aber ich probiere mal, was passiert, wenn ich woanders lang gehe.
Okay.
Nichts.
Das wundert mich.
Ich hätte jetzt Call of Duty mäßig eigentlich erwartet,
dass sie verlassen das Kampfgebiet oder sowas.
Hey Guards, was geht?
Nosecorp aus der Hüfte.
Oh, fuck.
Wow.
Okay, der Nosecorp aus der Hüfte ist nicht so klein.
Aber ich glaube, ich sollte es schon ordentlich machen.
Wo muss ich eigentlich hin?
Ah, guck mal da.
Da oben muss ich hin.
Mit Scope aus der Hüfte.
Klar.
Wir müssen jetzt den Heli-Stelz machen hier.
Wo spielt das Ganze?
In Utsirikriksan oder so?
Das Land gibt es nicht.
Das Land ist wahrscheinlich...
So irgendwie ein russisches Grenzland angelehnt.
Sowas irgendwie zwischen Russland und...
Keine Ahnung.
Da wo Uzbekistan ist oder so heute.
Oh, guck mal.
Eine Art COG.
Ein Red Dot.
Peter.
Jet.
Jetzt kommt der Heli-Stelz.
Ach nee.
Wir sprengen den Heli in die Luft.
Okay.
PP-Hands.
Ja, Leute.
Wenn es euch dann besser geht...
Chat.
Wenn es euch besser geht, einmal F für den Hund.
Beastmode.
Auf und ein Tausend.
Dankeschön.
Aber sowas ist der Twitch-Chat immer dabei, ne?
Aber sowas ist der Chat dabei.
Da geht's weiter.
Achtung.
Wir machen jetzt Slide.
Slide-Action hier.
Nice.
Jetzt.
Oh.
Na, das ist ja aber mal ein geiler Ölfilter.
Das darf ja auf jegliche Waffe alles sein, als er draufpasst.
Nicht schlecht.
Oh.
Da war ein Erwachen.
Komm mal hier.
Side.
Moment.
Das war doch gerade der Pilot, dem wir da von hinten entgegen gekommen sind.
Ist der hier runtergefallen?
Ich höre übrigens Schritte.
Ich höre Schritte.
Ich höre Schritte da unten.
Kann man von hier oben noch ein paar Russen bashen oder so?
Da klitscht irgendwas durch.
Ah, das ist Pharah, die da unten lang rennt.
Das waren die Schritte von Pharah.
Hätte ich mal das Chatpack.
Okay, das war schlecht.
Gebe ich zurück.
Wann kommt eigentlich das Overwatch?
Das Overwatch-Cod-Cross?
Das Overwatch-Cod-Cross.
Ich bin doch schon da.
Schon am Start.
Okay.
Blow it up.
Ey.
Hatte das irgendeinen Zünder dran?
Gar nicht.
Auf geht's.
Russen bashen.
Was?
Left?
Da.
Da schießen wir jetzt natürlich nicht drauf.
Wir sind ja die Guten.
No happy meal for you.
Dankeschön.
Vier Monate in Folge.
Krasser Scheiße.
Das sieht natürlich auch keiner, ne?
Pharah schon mit auf den Hintergrund.
Alter.
Was sollen die Feministen hier von dem Stream denken?
Das ist family-freundlicher Stream.
Ich darf jetzt.
Das geht nicht.
So.
Geht das hier?
Okay, jetzt kann ich wieder.
Fuck, wo ist sie hin?
Ich weiß nicht.
Weiter vorne.
Einmal nicht hingeguckt, schon ist sie weg.
Oh.
Hallo? Kannst du mal ein bisschen schneller rennen?
Krasser Elite-Soldat.
Das Rebellen-Grill
rennt doppelt so schnell wie Alex.
Dabei ist Alex hier
einer der Besten, der Besten von den Besten.
Übrigens, Doppelsprint geht in der Kampagne
irgendwie nicht, merke ich gerade.
Und wo sind die Russen
von vorne? Die Russen kommen bekanntlich
immer nur von einer Seite.
Ihr wollt mir doch jetzt nicht erzählen, dass sie mich nicht finden.
Das erinnert mich
an die Sniper-Mission.
Der läuft nämlich drüber.
Nee, der läuft an mir vorbei. Hab ich nochmal Glück, ja.
Wisst ihr was? Wisst ihr was?
Oh, wir
machen jetzt den krassesten Bash aller Zeiten.
Ha!
Weggesprayt.
I like your style, hä?
Schon haben wir Fahrer voll beeindruckt.
Mit unserem krassen
Quick-Spray.
Wo ist
dein Fahrer jetzt schon wieder hin?
Okay, Moment, wir probieren jetzt mal, ob er
schneller sprintet.
Mit Waffen wegstecken, sprintet man auch nicht schneller.
Ich finde das echt krass,
dass das Rebellen-Grill
so schnell sprintet, wie der, wie der übelste Elite-Soldat.
Oh, nee, jetzt hab ich voll auf Fahrer geballert.
Rekt.
You're a madman. Jawoll.
Das war wahrscheinlich
auch nicht so gedacht. Jetzt testen wir mal,
wie viel Mühe sie sich gegeben haben.
Okay.
Ein bisschen.
Keine Mühe. Doch.
Bisschen Mühe gegeben. Keine Mühe gegeben.
Ähm.
Wen?
Wen nicht Mühe gegeben.
Aber ansonsten,
also von der Beleuchtung her,
finde ich das ganz hübsch.
Wollen wir hier rein sliden?
Grenades? GIF?
Geht natürlich nicht.
Ist das Pair-to-Pair-Verbindung oder Server?
Angeblich alle Server.
Jetzt hoch oder runter?
Oh, jetzt müssen wir den Tunnel schelzen.
Wir sind der krasse
Styler aus den USA.
Wir klettern nicht einfach nur, ähm,
wir klettern nicht einfach nur die Treppe runter,
wir sliden die Treppe runter.
Geht das?
Ja, wir müssen Fahrer beeindrucken.
Nee, das geht nicht.
Oh nee, man muss mit
mit Animation.
Asht werden.
Ja.
Das ist aber irgendwie ein bisschen MonkaS, so mit dem Ding hier durchs Haus zu laufen, oder?
Guck mal, wo der hingeht.
Ach, ich darf nicht hinterher.
Ach, was haben wir da?
Haben wir noch mehr Waffen?
Das?
K98.
Naja, ein bisschen mehr Zweiter-Welt-Kriegs-Flair.
Komm, eine AK-47 und ein K98.
Ja, bessere Kombi geht auch eigentlich gar nicht.
Es gibt Drohnen-Stells, hä?
Ah, nee, AC-Planes.
Okay, Drohnen-Stells.
So, so.
Rechte Maustaste macht nichts.
Oh, linke Maustaste gibt Gas.
Jawoll.
Was die Rebellen in Uzikistan alles haben, hä?
Die Russen scheinen wieder mal nicht die Hellsten zu sein.
Der Rüpel, Stufe 1, vier Monate.
Dankeschön.
Nice.
Ricky OMFG, dankeschön.
Ähm, Void Danny ist auch am Start.
Tommy Lee 070, Bastion Prime 1996, Beast Mode, Game Sick und ich glaube, Independent Astoria hatten wir schon.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs.
Big Brain Subs.
High IQ, sag ich dazu mal noch.
Jetzt holen wir erstmal eine gute K98 raus.
Und bashen die Russen.
Man kann nicht, man kann nicht quickscopen mit der K98.
So kann ich, so kann ich nicht arbeiten.
Man kann nicht quickscopen.
So kann ich nicht arbeiten, Leute.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Jawoll.
Yeah.
Ja, ja, du bist der.
Okay, jetzt werden die Russen gebasht.
Weiß jemand, ob FFA noch da ist?
Ja.
Oh, komm.
Wie, es gibt kein Free-For-All?
Ernsthaft jetzt?
Pass auf jetzt.
Huge, huge aim.
Damn.
Collateral.
Next.
Doch, Server sind überlastet.
Ah ja.
Okay.
Oh, das...
What?
MP5, ich brauche einen MP5.
MP5, give.
MP5.
Jawoll.
Beste.
Jetzt haben wir gewonnen.
Jetzt kann eigentlich nichts mehr passieren, wenn wir einen MP5 am Start haben.
Ja.
K98, MP5.
Ein komplettes deutsches Waffenarsenal, was im Game drin ist, weiß nicht, ob es noch mehr
gibt.
Mit der AUG hätten wir noch ein bisschen Österreich reinbringen können.
AUG, warte mal, AUG?
Ne, Schweiz, oder?
Österreich?
Schweiz?
Okay.
Moment.
Ich soll wieder so ein Flugzeug reinfliegen.
Ja.
Ah.
Äh.
So.
Nee, Everyuse?
Schon mal Hacker-Funk funktioniert.
Is krars.
Hab jetzt so einen德.
Aber das war nicht gut funktioniert.
Nochmal.
Jetzt aber.
Jawoll.
300 IQ-Flugzeug.
Hi, Happen.
911, danke.
Ach, der jetzt.
Wie Bruce Lee...
Irgendwie sind sie dauernd, die russ...
E hij es.
Erstmal MP5...
Und...
die hat ein bisschen wenig schuss die mp5
da gibt es ein bisschen mehr schuss für
die russen schnellsten von allen seiten du kommst nicht rein
what what und wo kam der dann via moto hat was gesagt
wo ist hier weg wo ist hier weg zuviel viele russen am start
hinter mir
btf das ist ein btf
das ist ein btf
das ist so die die random call of duty sports jetzt auch im single player
so die die random call of duty sports jetzt auch im single player
okay wir müssen das anders machen ich glaube wir müssen mit uns für
okay wir müssen das anders machen ich glaube wir müssen mit uns für teammates stellen das will das
teammates stellen das will das
teammates stellen das will das geld von uns die waffe die war im
geld von uns die waffe die war im
geld von uns die waffe die war im multiplayer übelst schlecht
multiplayer übelst schlecht
multiplayer übelst schlecht was du musst das objektiv machen ja da
was du musst das objektiv machen ja da
was du musst das objektiv machen ja da will ich doch hin
will ich doch hin
will ich doch hin also meine team jetzt fast schon wie
Multiplayer...Kanate? Die nennen wir jetzt. Die nennen wir jetzt. Jawoll, LMG legit! Jetzt da...da geht nix. Richtig legit. Oh, ne SCAR. Da nennen wir doch lieber die SCAR mit, bevor wir da mit der LMG rumholzen.
Flashbangs...Ammo...Weg. Alter! Alter! Warum? Ich hab die Waffe geswappt!
Huh! Das war knapp. Oh Gott! Alter! Was soll das?
Okay, dann swappen wir jetzt die hier so rein. Wobei, ich wollte die SCAR haben. SCAR, gib SCAR.
Wir machen jetzt einfach nen Molotow dahinten, denn da können die gar nicht reinlaufen.
Das ist...next level. Schon pre-mollied.
War random irgendwo dahin geschossen. Fivehead! Aber richtig Fivehead, Leute!
Oh, das ist down. Das fliegt da oben. Erstmal Granate abwarten.
Wenn die mal explodiert. Jawoll.
Oh, die SCAR macht gut Damage. Die SCAR macht echt gut Damage.
Da sind die ja fast One-Hit mit der SCAR. Guckt euch das mal an!
Damn! Zwei-Hit. Two-Hit.
Two-Hit mit der SCAR.
SCAR ist nice. Die müssen wir im Multiplayer auch mal ausprobieren. Die gab's in der Beta ja noch nicht.
Nix mehr da.
Toll. Checkpoint.
Tarmac. Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass es am Flughafen keinen einzigen Spot gibt, der sich Tarmac nennt und die das einfach nur immer gerne in News-Sendungen oder in Spielen verwenden?
Es gibt offiziell am Flughafen nichts, was Tarmac heißt.
Das ist Big Brain jetzt. Hier lernt man auch noch was.
Ich nehm die AUG. Moment, wo war...
Ich nehm ne AUG, wenn ich ne AUG finde, okay?
Wenn ich ne AUG finde, nehm ich die AUG.
In der Ammo-Kammer. Okay.
Dann brauch... dann... dann...
Wenn du... wenn du... wenn du Twitch Prime subst, dann hol ich die AUG.
Easy sellout. Easy life.
Okay. AUG.
Heli stellt's.
Destroy Helicopter. Gut.
We can call off duty. Wir wissen schon...
Muss ich den Heli jetzt zerstören mit... Ah. Ah.
Damn. Jawoll.
Ganz schön sneaky. Drei Monate lang schon.
Au.
Warum machst du die Tür auf hier?
Wolltest du nicht die Tür aufmachen, wenn ich da grad drinne steh?
Die gehen wir nicht lang. Die gehen hier lang.
Dann stellst du uns außen vorbei.
Und quickscopen die Russen weg.
Einrennen ist in dem Spiel wirklich keine allzu gute Idee.
Das Feuer sieht cool aus. Das hab ich mir noch nicht so genau angeguckt, ehrlich gesagt.
Oh, das ist meiner.
Das ist cool. Der kommt von der Seite und ist fast...
Wo kommt... der Rus... die spawnen. Die spawnen einfach mitten drin.
Ich glaub, das Game möchte mir...
...sagen, ich soll mehr diese...
...diese Stellsmechanik hier benutzen.
Guckt schon, funktioniert das.
Wenn man... wenn man... wenn man die echte Stellsmechanik nimmt, dann ist es kein Problem.
Hat der da drin übernachtet? Was ist mit dem los?
Ich find es toll, dass die Gegner so mitten da drinne spawnen.
So, als wollten sie das gar nicht verstecken, dass die da drinne spawnen.
Gegner flashen auch. Das ist aber richtig Wahnsinns jetzt, ey.
Oh, der lebt noch. Fuck.
Ich hab grad Pharah abgeknallt und...
...voll.
Checkpoint. So ist gut.
Elite-Soldat, aber kann ich im Laufen nachladen.
Was hast du denke, die Stadt ist eine Anlehnung an Kyrgyzstan?
Kein Schimmer.
Ich kenn mich da geografisch so in... in... ähm...
...Ost... Osteuropa nicht so... nicht so gut aus.
Jalla.
Oh, oh, oh.
Du bist der RPG.
Das ist nicht Osteuropa.
Sag doch nicht, mich nicht auf...
Alter, ist ja gut.
Spawnt nicht hinter mir.
Asien?
Ja, Asien grenzt an Osteuropa.
Weg.
Weg. Nicht wieder aufstehen. Bleibst du liegen?
Ja, der bleibt liegen.
Okay, Doorpreach. Slow-Mo-Doorpreach jetzt.
Fuck.
Oder auch nicht.
Das... das hat so nach Doorpreach...
Fanden die nicht auch, dass das so sehr nach Slow-Mo-Doorpreach geschrien hat?
Achtung, Achtung.
Bam.
Ha? Next, Big Brain.
Big Brain.
Das habt ihr natürlich alle überlebt da drin, ganz klar.
Make it quick. Enemy Reinforcements are here.
Oh, ne SCAR.
SCAR oder PKM. Also ich behalte mal die PKM.
Und der SCAR muss... muss mal...
Oh, was haben wir denn da sonst noch?
Einen Grenade-Launcher.
Ja, so einen Grenade-Launcher ist, glaub ich, auch nicht verkehrt.
Aber dann nehm ich... mach ich lieber die PKM weg und nehm den Grenade-Launcher dann.
Fuck.
Tup-Tup.
Iih.
Wirklich aus.
Ja, ich bin schon auf dem Weg.
Oh, da kommt was.
Da kommt was angestellt.
Jackporn.
Okay, jetzt.
Das heißt, wenn die Call of Duty Jackporns kommen, dann passiert immer irgendwas.
Was jetzt?
Grenade.
Bashen.
Jetzt.
Oh, Granatwerfer.
Moment.
Granatwerfer.
Was ist das?
Oh, wir bashen.
Wir bashen jetzt den LRW.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, wir bashen doch nicht den LRW.
Den... den Molotow kommt.
Air Support.
Jawoll.
Ah, unser Sniper.
GIF-R ist rumgebrochen.
Chopper Gunner.
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
Ihr müsst mir die Controls nicht erklären!
Ich hatte den im Multiplayer schon.
Get shacked!
Ja, erst mal alles mit Raketen in die Luft sprengen.
Easy Apache, easy life.
Alles down.
Ne, da rennt noch was.
angeschossen und es war aber kurzer kurzer chopper
gar nicht spaß jetzt
also die bank ist anscheinend der böse ich bin ich blicke ehrlich gesagt nicht
durch wehrkraft gegen wen und wer sich bestellen als commander krieger die
commander karim
das hatten sie in kopf 4 doch auch
ok also hausstürmen gab es doch auch diese safe house mission in kopf 4 und
diese vier häuser stürmen musste erst mal kurz vor obi eingekauft vorher und
jetzt geht es auf die mission den haben wir denn hier war die ruhe kann ja
aussprechen talani price binder und park wie heiße ich noch mal
wie heißt ich weiß nicht wie der held ich meine hier die die die die wie nennt
man das so die diese einzelnen szenen das sieht schon ganz cool gemacht also
wir kommen auf die verhältnisse ja das echt ganz okay aus aber das ist halt
auch wie gesagt maximum an grafik mal ins haus gucken was da los ist was los
kann man da ein job ins haus
dpa
bitte
warum muss ich die leiter hochklettern wenn die einfach durch die tür gehen
können und die treppe hoch laufen
oder warum warum können die sich auch mit der leiter klettern
tactical tactical weiter beste kann man nichts machen
was sie da nicht mitgekriegt und ich habe instant instant getriggert die waffe
naja also wenn also wenn das jetzt nicht die aktive klammer ist dann kommt der taktik
an die klammer hat man den hals an den kamen und dann kann man mit ihm losgehen
also wenn also wenn das jetzt nicht deaktiviert ist dann kann man ja halt des knicks machen
wie war das nochmal lamer vor der sache ich hab in k verkauf den tag geworfen
um alles zu sagen also wenn das jetzt nicht deaktiviert ist dann kann man da nehmt
also wenn also wenn das jetzt nicht deaktiviert ist dann kann man nehmt
Also wenn, also wenn das jetzt nicht deaktiviert gewesen wäre, hätte ich die jetzt gleich abgeknallt aus Versehen.
Wollt ihr denn nicht den Mund zukleben oder sowas, dass ihr nicht rumschreit?
Achtung.
Oh, oh.
Oh, nee, nee, nee, hier.
Nee, nee.
Moment.
360.
Passt.
Man muss die Terroristen schon mit Style erledigen, ja.
Der, der, äh, Song.
Was soll das?
Was, was schubst du mich hier einfach weg von der Treppe?
Ich heiße Kyle.
Stimmt, ich heiße Kyle, ja.
Auf welcher Schwierigkeit nochmal?
Rumgeschrei im Hintergrund.
Stellsession.
Moment.
80 Geräte.
Ähm.
Waschbecken zerstören.
Ah, sie haben sich Mühe gegeben.
Ich meine, dass man die Waschbecken zerstören kann, das hätte sie in Call of Duty vorher nicht gegeben.
Die Badewanne nicht.
Das Klo auch nicht.
Die Klopapier.
Die Klopapier auch nicht.
Das ist natürlich interessant, dass man das Waschbecken zerschießen kann, aber das Klopapier absolut intakt bleibt.
Aber so haben sie sich auch schon verhältnismäßig viel Mühe gegeben.
Benutz mal die Toilette.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das geht.
Geht nicht.
Ich kann die, kann die Toilette mehlen.
Wisst ihr was?
Kann man hier, kann man hier Rainbow Six Style machen?
Oh, huge.
Oh.
Ich glaube, ich habe...
Ich glaube, ich habe die Geisel gerade gekillt.
Das kann ich so nicht auf mich sitzen lassen.
Wir, wir, wir...
Loads Skavars jetzt.
Saved.
Fuck.
Alter, was ist mit den, was ist mit den, mit den Grills in dem Haus los?
Warum wollen die alle mich erschießen?
Ich meine, vor allem, ist die...
Ist die bescheuert?
Die wird erst als Geisel von dem genommen, vor sich gehalten.
Ich rette sie und dann will sie mich...
Ich rette sie und dann will sie mich erschießen?
WTF?
Ich wollte eigentlich gerade eine Granate rein schmeißen, nachdem ich die Tür, nachdem
ich ein Loch in die Tür gemacht habe.
Sieht aus wie meine Heizung.
Warum halten die die Waffen eigentlich so cringe, Shep, im Stealth-Modus?
Nimm mal die Fall.
War da eine Fall?
Oh, huge Fall.
Ja, ich meine, man braucht schon so eine komische Pistole, ne?
Aber wir sind hier in der übelsten Stealth-Modus.
Ja, ich meine, man braucht schon so eine komische Pistole.
Ja, ich meine, wir brauchen schon so eine komische Pistole.
Nimm mal die Fall.
War da eine Fall?
Oh, huge Fall.
Ich meine, wer braucht so eine komische Pistole, ne?
Aber wir sind hier in der übelsten Stelzmission.
Ich kann nicht einfach mit der Fall rumwäschen.
Das geht nicht.
Wir müssen erstmal stelzen.
Oh, das ist das Treppenhaus.
Erstmal krass durch die Tür gestelzt
und dann kommen wir im Treppenhaus raus.
Weg mit dem Nachtsichtgerät.
Jawoll.
Ich weiß, dass das
an dem Nachtsichtgerät hängen liegt,
aber die halten das so.
Oben ist eine Frau mit Baby hier.
No-Spoiler-Blitz.
Was, jetzt weiß ich ja schon, dass ich aufpassen muss.
Was ist da hinten?
Nix. Da ist Bryce in der Tür.
Da kommt sie nicht vorbei.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Guck mal, die haben so gemacht, dass der hinwegzieht.
Achtung, Leute. Jetzt.
Weggeflasht.
Hier doch.
Easy Zugriff.
Es ist cool gemacht.
Ich finde, es ist echt cool gemacht bis jetzt.
Gefällt mir bis jetzt, wirklich.
Ich meine, ihr wisst, dass ich Games nie
so richtig ultra ernst nehme, ja.
Also selbst die Games,
die ich echt spannend finde.
Und bis jetzt ist es wirklich cool gemacht.
Ich nehme das nie so ernst, dass ich da so voll mitfieber.
Weil, das wisst ihr ja, ne.
Oh, man hört schon das Kind schreien.
Jetzt müssen wir aufpassen.
Weg.
Alles gut.
Guck mal, ob sie sich hier auch Mühe gegeben haben.
Ja, das ist ein Physikobjekt.
Auch.
Oh, guck mal.
Sogar der Teddy, der Teddybär geht kaputt.
Ah, sie haben sich doch schon ganz gut Mühe gegeben bei dem Game.
Okay, wo ist der Terrorist?
Der stellt es bestimmt hier.
Ja, jetzt, jetzt machen wir,
jetzt machen wir die Rainbow Six,
den Rainbow Six stellt.
Ah, da war er.
Oh, man kann ja sogar in die Leichen reinschießen.
Geht sonst nicht.
Ach, hier geht's weiter.
Ein bisschen schneller dürfst du schon laufen, Elite-Soldat.
Ist erlaubt.
Bash.
Erstmal ne Flash reinzimmern.
Was?
Was hast du gemacht?
Der Detonator!
Das war aus Thyroid.
Das beißt ertönt!
Das durchleuchten wir nicht.
Was sagst du denn da?
Oh, YouTube.
Die andere Person hat l hehe.
Und stolltes gesagt,
dominate posters los Dollar an Macron,
gemacht ein Dattle.
Weil es ja nicht durch sondern hinverfolgt.
In$$мос.
Dank Mount.
Und Timo B Fantasie!
Eun idei!
Leute, habt ihr es gesehen?
Habt ihr die IP gesehen?
Oh.
257 IP.
Big Brain.
Wobei, das ist bestimmt Absicht gewesen für Leute, die es kapieren, oder?
Alles klar.
Erklärung?
Mach ich gleich.
Ich erklär's gleich.
Das ruckelt.
Das ist normal.
Das ist ein Bug.
Das Zwischensequenzen ruckeln.
Da kann ich nichts machen.
Ja, aber ihr.
Aber ihr natürlich.
Die Katzen ziehen gut aus, Harris.
Sie werden den Wolf verurteilt.
Also müssen wir jetzt den Wolf verurteilen, nicht dass Peter kommt.
Und du?
Wo wirst du, wenn das vorbei ist?
Wo immer sie mich senden.
Du wählst nicht.
Nicht genau.
Reste auf.
Morgen ist ein großer Tag.
Was ist mit dir und deinen Männern?
Wir werden hier sein, bis die Sonne aufsteht.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen...
Ich werde den offenen Korner öffnen.
Ich meine, die haben jetzt ja Pharah hier eingeführt, so als Rebellenanführerin und sowas.
Und ihren Bruder und so.
Und man spielt halt hier selbst Alex.
Ich könnte wetten, dass man später in der Kampagne irgendwie quasi sich entscheiden muss, ob man Pharah killt oder nicht.
Das würde so voll in die Call of Duty Logik passen.
Passlich.
Echo 3-1.
Sergeant Griggs.
All day.
Call me Alex.
No locals on this one.
Not my call.
You Kareem?
All day.
Griggs!
Nice work, Ed in the Russians.
We share friends and enemies.
Ist das der reale Griggs?
Den gab's doch in Code 4 auch schon.
Die watschen Griggs, den gab's doch in Code 4 auch.
You'll find this a target-rich environment.
Guck mal.
Könnt ihr euch daran erinnern?
Griggs, Code 4.
Ja.
Ah, da isser.
Da isser.
Ja, da haben sie sich halt ein bisschen inspirieren lassen.
Boah.
Übel sneezen.
Also mal zur Erklärung.
Zur Erklärung mit der IP.
Ähm.
Das ist eigentlich relativ einfach.
Das höchste was möglich ist, das sind 32 Bit.
Die höchste Zahl, die irgendwie möglich ist, ist, wenn du das immer in 4x8 Bytes aufteilst.
Ähm.
Dann ist ja quasi
das höchste, wenn du 1 Byte hast,
die höchste Zahl ist 255.
Und zwar, wenn du alles 1er hast.
Das heißt, 257 als IP geht gar nicht.
Das geht von 0 bis 255.
257 als IP geht nicht.
Aber das ist bestimmt, das haben die bestimmt absichtlich reingeschrieben, dass das, dass die Kenner quasi, ne?
Die Kenner das erkennen.
Richtig big brain boost.
Those guys look like bad guys around here.
Shit's fucked up.
Das ist Griggs am Start.
Das find ich cool.
Viper, where you at?
Where you at?
Viper is rolling northbound.
By the end.
Oooh.
What the fuck?
Ey, ist doch gut.
Was für ne Taste soll das da oben sein?
Shift?
Oder was soll mir das sagen?
Soll das Shift heißen?
Okay, tatsächlich, das bedeutet das Shift.
Aber ganz ehrlich, keiner, der dann irgendwie
ein normales Auge hat, kann das lesen, dass es Shift heißen soll, was da oben steht.
Können die lesen, dass es Shift heißt?
Ich nicht.
You got tripwires on the outcome.
Oh, Sergeant.
What's the word, 3-1?
Oh.
Can you disarm it?
Check.
On it.
Okay, Moment, Leute.
Mal was testen.
Handle these wire traps, 3-1.
Und zwar...
Oh.
Äh...
Na gut.
Ich wollte nur testen, ob das funktioniert.
Aber es funktioniert.
Und was interessant ist, anscheinend stuft das das Game nicht als Friendly Fire ein.
Das ist ja...
Ich nehm mal seine Waffe mit.
Aber ich hab selbst ne M4.
Da will ich seine Waffe nicht.
Clip.
Achtung.
Ich bin vor dir, Auto.
Auto, ich bin vor dir.
Sorry, Leute.
Ich muss das nochmal ausprobieren.
Ich will...
Ich will nämlich wirklich checken...
Oh.
Das war sogar der Quicksave an der Stelle.
Ich will checken, wie viel Mühe es sich mit dem Game gegeben hat.
Ich will sehen...
Ich will sehen, ob die Autos anhalten, wenn ich vor ihnen bin.
Top.
Wahnsinnig.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich mich mit dem Game verabschiede...
Oh.
Jedes Mal, wenn wir neu laden, sehen wir jetzt...
Sehen wir jetzt, wie es den Typ zerreißt!
Das ist schon ein geiler Speicherpunkt, Alexander.
Not again.
Ja, der hat sein Geld verdient, der Typ.
Sie verlassen das Schlachtfeld?
Jawoll.
War klar.
War klar!
Wow.
Wisst ihr, ich stehe am Arsch der Welt, aber krieg erst mal so ne Slow-Mo.
Oh.
Ist das hoch.
Oh Fuck.
Ist das hoch!
Da kann man als Elite Soldaten irgendwie nimm.
Die wollen, dass wir das양.
da schon mal strugglen, dass man da nicht drüber kommt.
Oh.
Leeres Level?
Da haben sie sich definitiv keine Mühe
gegeben. Das ist komplett leeres
Level hier dahinter. Komplett
Basic-Level-Editor mit Sandtextur.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Au.
Oh, what?
Wie kommt der Dude
dahin? Der war doch eben noch nicht da.
Oh, ja, oh.
Haben wir gesmoked.
Wischt.
Haben wir hier? Ne, das sind unsere.
Das sind unsere.
Ups.
Der ist aber auch selten dämlich gerade vor mich
gerannt.
Oh, guck mal, der M14.
Alter, was ist hier los?
Das ist quäl die Schießen um die Ecke.
Wo kommt denn der her?
Ist der gerade vom Dach gesprungen?
Die M14 ist nice.
Die haut übelst rein.
Okay.
Okay. Next.
Noch Smoke. Erstmal Smoke.
Damit man durch kann. Was haben wir denn hier?
Eine AK. Eine AK kann man nimmer mitnehmen.
Da macht man nichts falsch.
Das ist ja so die Feld-, Wald- und Wiesen-Terroristen-Waffe
quasi in dem Game.
Oh, hier sind wieder
Grenades.
Danke schön für den Zap.
Zock. Baste.
Baste. Terror?
Warum kann ich die Granate nicht zerschießen?
Die diffusen wir diesmal.
Ja.
Nee, nee, ich teste diesmal nicht.
Oder soll ich wieder testen, Leute?
Was meine ich? Soll ich testen?
Oder soll ich diffusen?
Testen.
Ich glaube, das Game
checkt es echt nicht, dass das Friendly Fire ist.
Das ist, glaube ich, verbuggt.
Wupp, lull.
Okay, das geht nicht kaputt.
All teams, rally with the convoy.
Was ist da?
Was hat man da?
Dragunov.
Eiber wäre schon nicht verkehrt, ha?
Schneiber?
Kann man den mal in die Schneiber mit?
Ich glaube, das ist so eine typische Call of Duty-Geschichte,
wo man über einen gewissen
Punkt laufen muss, dass es weitergeht.
Eng.
Ja, dicker.
Jetzt nur noch Trickshots.
Da ist meine Sense nicht hoch genug.
Ich muss in Deckung.
Ich bin in Deckung.
Fuck, leer.
Smoke.
Eine Runde Smoke.
Jetzt hier.
Ach, da kann man auch.
Da kann er nirgendwo drüber hüpfen.
Äh.
Alles tot?
Jawohl.
Reiner.
Autsch, Autsch.
Die hauen echt gut rein.
Ich glaube, ich muss wirklich mehr diese Cover-Mechanics verwenden.
Dann treffen die nämlich auch nicht so gut.
Guckt hier, easy.
Geht's?
260.
Oh, oh.
Alter.
Die machen aber echt Damage, wenn du da rein slidest.
Okay, wir wissen jetzt ja, dass da links einer stellt.
Warum machen die so viel Damage?
Ich hab schon auf normal gestellt, oder?
Die warnen hinten einen ja fast.
Alter.
Ach, guck mal.
Bei dem aus dem Rucksack kann man sich, äh, ne Grenade nehmen.
Cool.
Ups.
Wo soll man das denn jetzt erkennen, so auf die Schnelle?
Oh, oh.
Oh, jetzt aber.
Ist nichts.
Krankenhaus-Level hatten wir auch noch nie.
Krankenhaus-Level.
Hat aber nochmal Glück gehabt, hier.
Grenade.
Wir brauchen ja drei Stunden.
So treffen die einen irgendwie gar nicht, ne?
Es ist ja fast, fast hier schon Cover-Shooter-Style.
Wo ist der nächste?
Next, please.
Hier.
Schau mal.
So.
Oh, oh.
Einer da
Der muss erstmal die KI geladen werden
Da würde ich auch immer stehen
Wenn ich Terrorist bin
Genau in dieser Ecke
Mach mal den Test
Ob wenn du lange um die Ecke schaust
Ob sie dich überhaupt treffen
Das ist eine gute Idee
Könnt ihr erstmal ausprobieren
Perfekt
Da musst du schneller sein
Okay testen wir das mal
Wenn ich um die Ecke gucke
Ob ich dann getroffen werde
Gucken wir mal um die Ecke
Aber ich glaube
Ich werde auch so nicht getroffen
Wo ist hier was
Lass mal hier durch
Da ist einer
Okay jetzt
Ich bleib mal hier stehen
Mal gucken ob ich getroffen werde
Die sehen mich überhaupt
Nicht
Guck mal die sehen mich überhaupt nicht
Oh fuck
Okay ich werde doch getroffen
Ui
Hedlisch
Hedlisch Taktik
What
Was war das
Bin ich über irgendeine Falle gelaufen ne
Fuck
Wo ist die Falle hier
Ach da
Jetzt okay
Jetzt müssen wir sie entschärfen
Nein ja nicht testen
Jetzt müssen wir sie wirklich mal entschärfen
Sind sie alle down
Alle geschreckt
Noch 5 Ammo
Und Schneiper haben wir
Dann nehmen wir mal
Dann nehmen wir mal hier eine AK mit
GIF
Jawoll
Vivi
Naja
Eigentlich nicht
Weil ich check auch nicht was passiert
Wie findest du dass es kein Free4All gibt
Kacke ich wusste gar nicht dass das so ist
Okay Leute Moment testen
Oh mo
Fuck
Ich hab mein
Ah
Da ist er wieder
Okay
Ich hab meinen Granatwerfer weggeworfen
Okay Sgt.
Krix macht es nix aus
Ja Krix hat Story Immunity
Das ist Hauptcharakter
Geh ich mal von aus
Der
Den kann man nicht killen
Da ist er
Der Wolf
Der
Der Hammer
Omar
Suleiman
Der Wolf
was der fuck ja was denn nur wenn ich zurückgehe bin ich ist die mission vorbei
und wenn ich an die tür ran gehe
aber jetzt hier die führung ist aber bei
der fuck game please sagt mir was ich machen soll
also jetzt haben wir es richtig gemacht wir haben den wolf gecapturiert
bei dem namen fällt mir ein hat jemand hier jack ryan staffel 1 geguckt gab es
doch auch in den schüler man ja die augen sehen bisschen kaputt aus
wahrscheinlich ist er blind ja das denke ich war dass sie einem was sagen
wollen jetzt aber ziemlich viel anhälter angesagt
die botschaft verteidigen das ist übrigens nicht bei euch aus dem grund
das backen um die katzen
ich will
sein
und merkt euch wenn ihr
immer möglichst kryptisch reden
das game hat 192 129 gigabyte
warum auch immer
er ist wieder da
wie es fps russia nicht auch teilen möchten leben ja 130 gigabyte
preis ist wieder am start
nein ich das nicht immer das gleiche
Wie ist Call of Duty?
Kann in Call of Duty nicht ein Heli
mal normal landen, indem man drinnen sitzt?
Onkais.
Easy.
Das ist ihm ins Gesicht geflogen.
Nee, nee, du hast dich verguckt.
Kann nicht sein.
Okay, ich glaube, wir müssen echt die Botschaft
verteidigen.
Okay, jetzt schauen wir mal. Schuss sicher.
Sag mal.
Ich meine, er ist der Ultra-Elite-Soldat,
aber da schleicht die Treppe langsam
als eine Oma runter.
Rutsch das mal an.
Komm vorwärts.
Die haben auch so ganz wenig
Klischee-behaftete Namen.
The Wolf, The Butcher.
Da ist er.
Soll ich da aufmachen?
Kann ich auf?
Soll ich jetzt aufmachen oder nicht?
Jetzt ist es eh zu spät.
Oh, macht der einfach die Tür vor mir zu.
Kannst du mir eine Waffe geben?
Wie ist das?
Da sind sie.
Erstmal reingeflankt.
Ich habe nur eine Pistole.
Ich brauche irgendwas Gescheites.
Die Pistole macht gefühlt mehr Damage
als die LMGs und
die Sword Rifles.
Ich kriege hier nicht irgendeine Waffe.
Ah, da.
Shotgun.
Shotgun nehmen wir doch hier Indoor rein.
Shotgun ist pock.
Damn.
Ja, Shotgun ist nice hier drin.
Granate.
Price juckt das nicht.
Price ist die Granate. Egal.
Hat Plot-Armor.
Das ist ein Rorschach.
Oh, die Shotgun hier drin ist schon cool.
Die hat sich jetzt gedacht, ich sehe dich nicht oder was?
Stellt sie hier vorbei so.
Oh, gleich komme ich von hinten.
Gleich komme ich von hinten.
Da passiert aber nichts.
Ist das eine Autoshotgun hier?
Ist das eine Autoshotgun oder ist das die gleiche?
Ist die gleiche.
Nein, nein, Price.
Ich mache schon auf.
Von Price gesaved.
Die geht auf, ist sie nur noch rechts.
Was ist das?
Das ist eine Autoshotgun.
Oh, sie was?
Ja, hier unten.
Nein!
Okay, wir müssen jetzt sehen was wir hier machen können.
Was?
Das ist eine Autoshotgun.
How did you do?
Was ist das?
Okay.
Und dann mache ich diese hier.
Okay, wir müssen schauen was wir hier machen.
So.
Und dann machen wir das hier.
Okay.
Dann machen wir das hier.
Okay, wir müssen schauen was wir hier machen können.
Ja.
Dann machen wir das.
Okay.
Okay, wir müssen schauen was wir hier machen können.
Es hat sich schon etwas geändert und das habe ich uns wieder geklärt.
Okay, du bist hier.
Ich brauche mal irgendwas Automatisches.
Äh, ja.
Gut.
SMG ist hier.
Indoor E ist das Beste.
Moin, peinlicher Affe.
Ja, komm.
Fahrer!
Wie kommt ihr denn da hin?
Ich wette mit dir, wenn ich ihn jetzt kille, ist die Story...
Dann muss ich neu laden.
Das geht nicht.
Okay, Überwachungsding.
Das da tut sich ganz schön dreckig aus, ne?
Ja, super clevere Idee.
Erstmal, wenn der Typ kommt, da hin zu laufen.
Big Brain.
Apple Pie TV, dankeschön.
Twitch Prime.
Big Brain.
Jetzt?
Oh, muss ich die Olli jetzt rumkommandieren?
Soll ich...
Ich muss Frauen in dem Game rumkommandieren.
Das dürfen aber nicht die falschen Leute sehen.
Das...
Ich bin...
Leute, ich bin...
Weiß, männlich, heterosexuell und 35.
Ich kann nicht in dem Game einfach Frauen rumkommandieren.
Das ist heute nicht mehr drin, ne?
Jetzt ist die große Preisfrage.
Ist das eine Mission, wo ich verlieren kann, oder ist das eine Mission, die einfach so funktioniert?
Wahrscheinlich kann...
Wahrscheinlich doch.
Ich muss aufpassen, dass sie mich nicht sehen.
Du kannst verlieren, okay.
Das heißt, ich gucke mal, bis die weggucken.
Jetzt gucken sie weg.
Das ist eigentlich...
Das ist eigentlich mal ganz cool, aber...
Abwechslung.
Oh, da kommt einer.
Da hin.
Das hat er natürlich jetzt nicht gesehen, ist klar.
Schnell, schnell, schnell.
Stacey, move.
Das habe ich echt ganz cool gemacht.
Ich meine, ob man das jetzt in einem Cod braucht, die Mission, weiß ich nicht so genau, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil in den Cod willst du reinrennen und bashen.
Oh, nein.
Stacey, bitte.
Lass ihn liegen.
Das sind Big Brain Soldaten hier.
Äh.
Geh.
Hinten.
Geh mal dahinter.
Oder da.
Geh mal dahin, Stacey.
Auf.
Bericht nicht.
Oh, nein, nein.
Stacey.
Die Office-Grills wieder.
Moment.
Wo bin ich?
Ich blick gerade nicht mehr durch.
Wo ist sie denn überhaupt?
Ach, da.
Hier, Stacey.
Einfach schneller sein.
Diesmal einfach schneller sein, bis der Dude sich umdreht.
Nicht durch die Mitte.
Alter.
Okay, jetzt.
Go, go, go.
Go.
Nein.
Nein, Stacey.
Du läufst immer falsch herum.
There's a guard block in the exit.
You'll have to distract him.
What do I need to do?
There's a large printer against the wall.
Hide there.
Jetzt.
Now use it.
The shredder.
Go, now.
Schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell.
Get to the exit.
Run.
Hopp.
Genau.
Jetzt läuft es übrigens die richtige Richtung.
Das kriegt er nicht mit.
Lol.
Ah ja.
Die Gegner sind schon ein bisschen braindead, oder?
Roger that, boss.
Okay.
Jetzt dürfen wir jetzt...
Jetzt müssen wir jetzt...
Okay.
Waffe überranged. Bam. Bam. Bam. Der lebt noch? Lebt der noch? Oh. Sorry, Captain Price.
Du sahst so Terroristen-mäßig aus. Au. Was gab's denn noch? Gar nichts? Achso, was ich
mir holen werde. Ich hole mir vorne am Mittag. Ich habe mir am Mittag Pizza bestellt und
zwar, halt euch fest, Sauce Hollandaise Pizza mit Brokkoli und Hähnchen. Ich weiß, ich
weiß, was die meisten Leute jetzt denken. Die meisten Leute denken jetzt halt irgendwie
sowas in der Richtung. Aber ich sag euch, das ist echt pock. Das ist nicht Dominos.
Ne, das ist nicht von Dominos. Dominos suckt. Dominos ist die schlechteste Pizza-Kette
ever. Was willst du? Ne, das verstehe ich nicht. Doch, hat er gesagt. Dominos suckt.
Übelst. Ich wurde nur enttäuscht, bis er Mensch bei Dominos bestellt hat. Die haben
ja Joey's Pizza in Deutschland gekauft. Das war noch ein bisschen besser. Ähm, da bestelle
ich, bestelle nie wieder was bei Dominos.
Ja, ja. Rein da.
Hör zu.
Sag mal dann, ne, M14? Ja, wir nehmen ne M14, M14 und ne Fall. Das ist über Range ganz
gut.
Sag mal, ich meine, Pharah ist doch eigentlich so die, die, ähm.
Anführerin, sodass das, das, äh, Miliz-Anführer-Grill, wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab. Warum
darf die auf irgendwelche Militärstützpunkte mit und, und, und stellt's damit, stellt's
damit Price rum? Haben die keine Bedenken, dass die vielleicht doch nicht so freundlich
gesonnen ist, der ganzen Sache? Ich meine, ich würde mir da Gedanken machen. Aber ich
glaube, ich glaube, das ist zu viel Gedanken, die ich mir da bei der Cod-Story mache. Jetzt
wird geschneibert. Jetzt gibt's nur noch 360-Header. Scope in. Wenn sogar Price sagt, die soll
scopen, dann ist er in. Military-Age-Males. So, warum keine Military-Age-Girls? Wie ist
das mit Gleichberechtigung? Das geht aber nicht. Darf ich da jetzt draufballern?
Die meisten Lieferservices da ist, geb ich dir recht, die meisten Lieferservices gefallen
mir auch nicht.
Wie ist das denn?
Es ist doch gut, wenn die herkommen, dann kann ich sie snipen. Wo bestellst du immer?
Ich bestell bei keinem Ketten mehr. Ich bestell bloß noch bei uns. Bei Asia stellst, Hähnchen
stellst.
Wo?
Bei der Modell-Modell, Pizza-Kram, Doodle. Die haben ja alles hier.
Meine doofen Fragen. Weiß jemand, wie lange die Kampagne geht, weil ich bin mir nicht
sicher, ob wir das heute hinbekommen bis 21 Uhr oder 22 Uhr.
5 Stunden, ach, das könnten wir packen.
Denix. Denix. Wo ist sowas?
Ok, ich soll was machen. Ich soll was machen. Ich weiß noch nicht, was ich machen soll.
Ok.
Ach, ich soll Mörser
Schießen
Die kommen jetzt da nur raus
Weil ich die Flare geschossen habe
Oder was
Komm, was soll man hier rumstelzen
Wir gehen da jetzt hin
Wäschen
Lass mich hier rüber
Ich darf nicht raus
Ich muss
Auf dem Dach bleiben, Leute
Geht nicht, das Game möchte von mir, dass ich auf dem Dach
Bleibe
Huge Level Design
Und jetzt muss ich wieder Flare schießen
Das Game ist sowas von Uncut
Ja, sehr ernsthaft
Wow, was jetzt
Wie ist da Gefahr, der Typ hält down
Ganz schön viele
Nochmal ne Flare
Nochmal ne Flare her
Voll
Warum bewegen die sich eigentlich nur, wenn ich ne Flare schieße
Ich dachte, die wollten uns angreifen und nicht wir, die
Oh, da kommt was
Da kommt was
Ich bräuchte wieder so ein Remote
So ein RC-Plane von vorhin
Kann man die nicht einfach killen jetzt
48 FPS
Weil es flüssiger läuft
Wow
Okay
Ich bin schon vom Roof runter
Meistens ist das so
Das ist der kleinste Prize, wie lange ich dafür brauche, wenn einer mit Mörser drauf schießt
Wow
Ich darf immer noch nicht rüber
Ich glaube, das ist nicht der intended way, wie ich das gerade mache
Wo muss ich hin
Defend, okay, einfach nur Defend
Ach, guck mal
Die Mauer ist kaputt
Das ist ja nice
War da was, Damage
Okay, wir machen Slider
Oh, fuck, nein
Da stehen ja um mich drum herum
Die sind gespawnt
Erstmal ne Granate rein
Das kann nicht schaden
Und jetzt ne Runde Flash drüber übers Auto
Zack
Jetzt werden sie gebasht
Ich habe immer noch das Gefühl, dass ich das nicht intended mache gerade
Hallo?
Wo kommst du her?
Ich glaube, ich mach das echt nicht intended, was ich hier
Ich glaube, ich sollte da drinnen sein
Und irgendwie Defender-Stells machen
Oh, nö
Go black
Okay, we go in black
Recruit
Wir sind fertig
Easy, wir haben es geschafft
Jetzt war es
Siehst du die Flares?
Ne, gibt keine Flares mehr
Man sieht echt nichts
Also bei mir sieht es in der Vorschau ganz okay aus
Ich meine, es ist halb Nacht
Ich habe 6.900 Bitrate
Der geht nicht
Das ist schon mehr als 90% der Leute auf Twitch streamen
Ich habe 6.900 Bitrate
Also ich sehe es gerade bei mir in der Vorschau
Das sieht doch ganz okay aus
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das Problem ist
Das ist halt so
Wenn das Bild dunkel ist
Und vor allem, wenn es ein paar Lichtquellen hat
Da tun sie alle Encoder schwer
Na, zum Glück liegt da eine Leiter rum
Easy
Laser, jetzt
Äh, okay
Okay
Oh, nice
Erst mal schön das Gebäude kaputt machen
Guck mal mal, wie viel wir vom Gebäude kaputt machen können
Wahrscheinlich nicht so viel
Nö, eigentlich so gut wie gar nichts
Wisst ihr was, ich muss mal was ausprobieren
Okay, das geht nicht
Man weiß ja nie
Also ich gucke es mir jetzt gerade in meiner Vorschau an auf Fullscreen
Also, das sieht einfach so aus, wie halt H.264 mit nicht so hoher Bitrate
H.264 mit nicht so hoher Bitrate
Japanische
Die
Wie
War
Macht
Tragik
Eins
Kannst du mal treffen, Alter?
Jawoll.
Rette Schreck, du.
Komm mit.
Es gibt nichts mehr.
Es gibt keine Raketen mehr.
Ah, doch wieder.
Raketen.
Jawoll.
Oh, die werden aber schon hart geschreckt, die Tuts hier.
Ich glaube, die Autos sind schon alle in die Luft geflogen.
Darf ich nicht, nuff.
Was?
Mit der?
Ah, der Laser ist all.
Batterie leer.
Runter hier.
Ne, Moment, hier darf ich nicht lang.
Hier darf ich nicht lang, das ist falsch.
Wo möchte Call of Duty, dass ich lang gehe?
Dahin, okay.
Mach ich.
Erstmal schön...
...butt-sliden zum Gegner, da treffen sie einen nicht.
Die sind eh nicht allzu clever, muss ich sagen.
Jawoll.
Oh, der hat schon eingeschlagen hier gerade.
Achtung jetzt hier.
Huge Nate.
Mach ich mal auf.
Gott.
Nein, ich mach das.
Weil es kotzt.
Okay, wir können...
Wir sind nicht in der Lage, die Tür aufzukriegen.
Ja, ist klar.
Natürlich.
Was sonst?
Guck dir die Gebäude an.
Die sehen ziemlich viereckig aus.
Da kämpft er.
Da kämpft er in der Ecke.
Fast wie ein Multiplayer.
Als wollen sie die Leute schon mal drauf vorbereiten, was sie erwartet.
Wie kommt denn die Granate in den Raum?
Wie kommt die Granate in den Raum?
Die ist mir im Gang entgegengeflogen gekommen.
What?
Da ist die Granate.
Wie ist die in den Raum gekommen?
Samtex?
Meinst du, die hat mich gestickt?
Ich glaube nicht, dass die mich gestickt hat.
Das war irgendeine Call of Duty Logik.
Alle Terroristen, go out.
Jawoll.
Alle weg.
Haben wir hier noch zu bieten?
Okay, let's get back to the compound.
Hier ist der AK.
Oder 15 Terroristen.
Gun.
Da kann man nichts falsch machen.
Da gibt es genug.
Oh, guck mal.
Uh.
LMG.
Fettes LMG.
Das behalten wir mal kurz.
Wo ging es raus?
Das lädt ja 5 Stunden nach.
Das ist für 50 Schuss.
Stelzen wir da mal rein.
Erstmal noch eine Flasche.
Naja, ich bin da schon wieder drin.
Ah ne, hier geht's gar nicht rein.
Alles andere, dass ich gerade Friendly
feiert habe.
Au, au, au, au, au, au, au.
Fort.
Pistisch, Alter.
Der ist schon down.
Das ist einer von mir.
Man erkennt gar nicht so genau, was Freund und Feind ist.
Irgendwie, ne?
Komische MG.
Ich brauch was anderes.
Das MG sackt.
Das braucht 5 Stunden zum Nachladen.
Ich will da 5 Stunden nachladen.
Guck mal.
Das bin ja ich.
Das fällt mir jetzt erst auf.
Pock.
Das finde ich cool, dass die die gleichen Spieler
in die gleiche Mission packen.
Also die Spieler-Charakter
Haben wir nicht genug?
Ja, ich...
Ich weiß, dass ich...
Es ist mir auch klar, dass ich jetzt Kyle bin.
Aber davor war ich Alex.
Das finde ich cool, dass sie die Spieler-Charaktere
in die gleiche Mission packen.
So, erstmal wieder was ordentliches nehmen.
Das war knapp.
Wo kommt denn Stacy auf einmal her?
Die ist von der Botschafter hingestellt.
Door-Breach.
Leute, jetzt endlich mal ein Door-Breach.
Nein, gibt kein Door-Breach.
Ja, die können das auch nicht.
Die Golden-Captain.
Wir werden ihn finden.
Hadir, bring dein Team auf die Crossroads.
Bring alles, was du hast.
Der Wolf ist weg.
Was war das für eine Pläne?
Der Wolf ist mit dem Butcher.
Terroristen-Selben in der Stadt werden sie verstecken.
Bravo wird Haus zu Haus in Suche klären.
Meine Leute werden dir helfen.
Wenn sie versuchen, in die Berge zu fliehen,
gibt es nur ein Weg.
Tariq Al-Mut.
Die Höhe des Todes.
Die Russen haben sie in der Invasion getötet.
Sie haben sie getötet.
Die Leute versuchen zu fliehen.
Es gibt ein Dorf an der Crossroads.
Ich habe Hadir und seine Kämpfer da, um eine Ambush zu vorbereiten.
Alex und ich werden sie mitnehmen und auf die Räume aufwachen.
Laufen und warten.
Für den Wolf.
So wirklich checke ich die Story jetzt ja nicht,
oder ist die Story einfach nicht vorhanden?
So nach dem Motto, die Russen,
oder besser gesagt, die Terroristen,
haben russisches Gas
und alle haben jetzt...
irgendwie Schüsse und wollen sie bashen.
Und das sind die Freiheitskämpfer.
Ich glaube, das hat einfach nicht mehr Story.
Bevor der Krieg, hatte diese Ville Familien und Lachen.
Lachen ist die beste Medizin.
Sag mir einen Joke.
Was passiert, wenn die CIA schläft?
Treffen sich zwei Jäger,
beide tot.
Nicht schlecht.
Wahrscheinlich besser als Englisch.
Du kannst nicht sagen, dass es so geht.
Mit dem los?
Will er den jetzt weghammern?
Ach ne, für mich sah das so aus, als will er dem den Kopf weghammern.
Guck mal, der steht mit dem Hammer da und der macht den Kopf so runter, als hämmert dem jetzt den Kopf weg.
338 Lapua, Schleifmessung auf 600 Meter.
Ich habe sie selbst zusammengelegt.
Bitte, benutze sie.
Saude, schütze sie mit deinem Leben.
Sie wird dir das gleiche tun.
Danke, Adir.
Perfekt für die Unterstützung.
Ich werde dich für dich bewegen, Alex.
Wir sind jetzt Brüder.
Mach mich stolz darauf.
Ich habe das Sniper-Gewehr ausgetauscht und schon ist man quasi, ja.
So Leute, ich muss mal hier Licht anmachen, ich muss mal was zu essen holen, ich habe übelst Hunger.
Ich hole mir jetzt die zwei Stücke Pizza vor der Mittag und ihr könnt euch mal überlegen, oder was mich mal interessieren würde, ich bin ja nur zwei, drei Minuten weg.
Was mich mal interessieren würde, was ihr bis jetzt von der Kampagne denkt.
Ich für meinen Teil muss sagen, ich habe irgendwie, ich habe am Anfang gedacht, ich blicke nicht durch, bis mir dann aufgefallen ist, es gibt eigentlich überhaupt nichts durchzublicken.
Es gibt nichts durchzublicken.
Es gibt Engländer, es gibt Russen und die Terroristen haben von den Russen Gas gestohlen und jetzt, guckt mal, was passiert.
So, das ist alles.
Und irgendwie ist es doch ein bisschen langweilig.
Ich habe mir jetzt eigentlich mehr davon versprochen, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
So, ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
Ich gehe mal kurz was zu essen holen.
So, ich bin wieder am Start.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal was essen kurz.
Oh, was?
Was gibt es denn sonst so Neues, worüber wir nochmal eine Runde schwätzen können?
Sagt mal, was gibt es denn für spannende Sachen, wo man mal was zu sagen muss?
Alle schon am pennen.
Man macht, was?
Man macht das Key-Server-Update?
Ähm, ach den.
Jetzt erstmal langsam.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal.
Ich habe euch jetzt erstmal dieses Scan-Zeug gemacht.
Und dann muss ich ja auch noch die fertige Sache, muss ich ja nochmal deinem Chef schicken, aber es geht es ja schon, benutzbar.
Und dann, wenn ich wieder Zeit habe.
Man sieht die Emotes nicht.
Emotes nicht.
Man sieht die Emotes.
Ach, man sieht die Emotes nicht.
Stimmt. Wisst ihr, warum man die Emotes nicht sieht?
Weil Display Capture und Game Capture.
Jetzt haben wir Display Capture.
Ich spiel Pega.
Ähm, ich glaube das lag, dass es ein bisschen geleckt hat, lag daran, dass ich Modern Warfare mit Display Capture aufgenommen habe und nicht mit, nicht mit Game Capture.
Und jetzt habe ich auf Game Capture umgestellt und seitdem, seitdem funktioniert es.
Vor Black Friday.
Ja, wieso es funktioniert, es funktioniert doch erstmal.
Was muss man denn wirklich nochmal Wichtiges machen?
Aber jetzt sieht man die Emotes wieder, ne?
Ja, ja, jetzt sehe ich es auch in der Vorschau.
Da sehe ich es auch wieder.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit Emotes eingeblendet und ihr habt die alle nicht gesehen.
Das ist ja kacke.
Das sagt ja.
Den haben wir hier noch als neuen Subs am Start.
Apple Pie TV.
Ganz schön sneaky.
Hi Happen.
Ach ne, hatten wir schon.
Aber trotzdem nochmal.
THX.
Ja, also.
Chat.
Ihr könnt jetzt irgendwas erzählen oder mich irgendwas fragen, wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt, weil ich muss jetzt eh noch meine Pizza futtern.
Wenn ihr nichts sagt, dann werde ich jetzt einfach 5 Minuten vor mich hinkauen.
Video schauen.
Was denn für ein Video?
Wie viele Haare hast du noch?
Keine Ahnung, ich habe nicht gezählt, aber jetzt nicht mehr so die Masse.
Ja.
Ne, es hält sich an Grenzen.
Wieso benutzt du Chromium?
Das ist relativ schwierig zu beantworten.
Ich weiß es selbst gar nicht so genau.
Äh, wie das ruckelt.
Ich, ich glaube.
Ich weiß es selbst gar nicht so genau.
Äh, wie das ruckelt.
Ich habe angefangen Chromium zu benutzen, weil irgendwas mit Chromecast gespackt hat.
Und, also, es hat insofern was mit Chromecast gespackt.
Ich wollte kein Chromecast verwenden, aber irgendwie hat es doch was mit Chromecast gemacht und hat immer drüben auf meinem Shield-TV rumgespackt am Fernseher.
Deswegen habe ich dann einfach einen Browser genommen, der eben kein Chromecast drinnen hat.
Aber mittlerweile ist das gefixt.
Eigentlich könnte ich wieder Chrome nehmen.
Ich meine, ich habe hier eh alles drauf.
Firefox drauf.
Chrome drauf.
Chromium drauf.
Opera in der VM drauf.
Vivaldi.
Ähm.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Edge.
Internet Explorer.
Ehe, alles drauf.
Ja, Max Blanco, so sieht es aus.
Das Gute ist, hier an dem Noise Gate, man hört mich gar nicht schwatzen, ne?
Ja.
Das ist auch schon mal gut.
Also, ich habe hier gerade die letzten zwei Stücke Pizza Hollandaise.
Das ist sehr nice.
Ich bräuchte einen Futter-Emo.
Also, das Overlay von COD ist nicht so ganz flüssig, würde ich sagen.
Wenn man das hier overlayt, da geht es besser.
Wo warst du die Jahre?
Äh.
Da, wo ich vorher auch war?
Oder was meinst du?
Also, auf Twitch bin ich schon seit...
Ich glaube, 2017 oder so.
Also, ungefähr vor zwei Jahren oder so habe ich angefangen, auf Twitch zu streamen.
Allerdings natürlich nicht unter meinem YouTube-Namen, weil das ursprünglich gar kein Account zum Streamen war.
Und bin ich ja schon wieder eine Weile auch auf YouTube am Start.
Kennst du das Windows 10 Deep Loader?
Ne.
Aber ich kann es mir mal angucken.
Probieren wir mal.
Was macht das?
Aha.
Also, das deinstalliert den ganzen Mist, der schallermäßig drauf ist, oder was?
Deinstalliert das auch Candy Crush?
Jawoll!
Das ist ja schon mal ganz sinnvoll.
Finde ich keine schlechte Idee.
Und ich meine,
als er 3000 Sterne auf GitHub,
das Ding scheint ja relativ beliebt zu sein, ne?
Ich muss ein bisschen COD im Hintergrund aufhalten, weil ich meine,
wir haben immerhin noch es auf der Kategorie Call of Duty stehen.
Wir machen auch gleich weiter.
Aber ich muss erst mal meine Pizza fertig futtern.
Was hältst du von der Einstellung der Win-Updates von Windows 7?
Ah, logische Konsequenz von dem, was Microsoft gesagt hat.
Es gibt eigentlich keinen Grund, nicht auf Windows 10 zu wechseln.
Oder wie sieht es eurer Meinung nach aus?
Falls noch jemand bei Windows 7 ist.
Warum seid ihr noch auf Windows 7
und wollt nicht auf Windows 10 wechseln?
Also aus meiner Sicht gibt es keinen Grund.
Warum?
Mit was ist die Pizza belegt?
Wie gesagt, Brokkoli, Sauce, Hollandaise und Hähnchen.
8 GB Update für Modern Warfare?
Okay.
Ich meine, wir sollten das Game nochmal neu starten.
Wobei, es läuft doch jetzt eigentlich ganz gut.
Danke für das schnelle Video zu VPN.
Ja, das war ein guter Thema, Frau Schlapp.
Weil du nicht der Einzige warst,
der das haben wollte.
Die Einstellungen sind total unaufsichtlich.
Es gibt die Systemeinstellungen.
Einmal neu und einmal an für Windows 7.
Das stimmt.
Da hast du recht.
Aber ich finde, es ist nicht wirklich ein Grund, nicht zu wechseln.
Ja, Windows 10 hat auch viel, was mich nervt.
Aber das macht die anderen, die alten Windows jetzt nicht besser für mich.
Windows 10 ist halt das Neueste.
Und das Neueste ist halt auch immer das am besten supportetste.
Allein schon deswegen macht es für mich so.
Ja, ich gebe dir recht,
dass es total unübersichtlich ist.
Das habe ich mich ja auch schon öfters im Stream drüber aufgeregt.
Wie unübersichtlich das Ganze ist.
Ähm.
Aber, also für mich
wäre es zumindest kein Grund.
Rasti Youtube
sagt, meine Schule ist noch
auf Windows 7.
Dann ist deine Schule aber schon voll fortschrittlich.
Nächstes Video.
AMD vs Intel.
Habe ich das nicht schonmal gemacht?
Glieder.
Der Auer hat das schon gemacht.
Das beschreibe ich mir mal auf.
Ähm.
Allerdings,
wenn es um AMD vs Intel geht,
kann ich sagen,
wenn ich mir aktuell einen Desktop Rechner
zusammenbauen würde,
dann würde ich es mit einer Ryzen CPU machen.
Weil,
die ganz neuen CPUs,
die Intel vorgestellt hat,
sind auch
wieder recht
konkurrenzfähig.
Aber da sieht man mal,
wie unglaublich viel Kohle Intel geschäffelt hat,
wenn die einfach mal so
die Preise für ihre CPUs halbieren können
und es sie nicht juckt.
Corazon 97i
Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Big Brain, High IQ Sub.
So, ein Stück Pizza noch, dann geht es weiter.
Also Official Dark Toasty,
ich würde dir empfehlen,
wenn du nur unter Windows spielen willst
und auch unter Linux
arbeiten willst, mach den Linux VM.
Linux VM habe ich ja auch hier
am Start.
Benutze ich ja auch immer regelmäßig im Stream.
Natürlich ist es ein bisschen
langsamer oder ein bisschen
ein paar Sachen nicht möglich,
die native möglich sind.
Beispielsweise Grafikkarte durchreichen oder sowas,
aber das will man meistens auch eh nicht machen.
Dafür hast du
den super Support,
was Hardware angeht und was
Spiele angeht und was Software angeht von Windows
und für alles andere kannst du Linux
in der VM verwenden. Ich nehme das immer auf den
Desktop.
Woher kennt dein Chef eigentlich deinen YouTube Channel?
Ah, da muss ich euch was erzählen, Leute.
Huge, huge
Story Inc.
Also,
um jetzt erstmal die Frage direkt zu beantworten.
Der kennt meinen
Channel, weil der mich auch
schon eine Weile kennt.
Und der mich schon kannte, bevor ich mit YouTube angefangen habe.
Der war ja
auch früher,
wie ich in dem einen Video erzählt habe,
da war ja auch mal Azubi bei diesem Internet
Provider, zwei Jahre
vor mir,
wo wir gearbeitet haben. Der war am gleichen Laden
früher.
Also, den kenn ich schon ziemlich lang.
Und der hat auch viel Battlefield 3 gespielt
und er hat sich damals
meine Battlefield 3 Videos angeguckt. Ich hab sogar noch
irgendwo nen Heli-Gameplay von dem.
Und ich mein, wer kann schon bitte schon sagen, dass
er von seinem Chef nen Battlefield 3 Heli-Gameplay hat?
Da gibt's nicht so viele,
ne?
Nekurock, Twitch Prime,
drei Monate. Oh, Big Brain, IQ
vom Chat steigt ins Unermessliche.
So, und jetzt wollt ich euch was erzählen.
Und zwar,
ihr werdet es nicht glauben, ne? Ich hab ja letztens,
das glaubt
mir wieder keiner.
Ich hab ja letztens ein Video gemacht,
ähm,
dazu.
Das mach ich auf der Arbeit.
So. Und ich hab
ja in dem Video am Anfang noch
gesagt, ich muss jetzt mal bei der
Realität bleiben, weil
ich weiß, dass mein Chef
manchmal zuguckt. Also ich hab
gesagt, ich darf's jetzt nicht so
übertreiben oder untertreiben.
Und da hab ich ja auch ein bisschen über
Arbeit, was man so macht, Gehalt
und sonst was.
Und am Freitag
quasi schon, als ich gehen wollte,
ich hab eigentlich gesagt,
ich hab keine Zeit, ich muss jetzt weg.
Da hat er gemeint, nee, komm doch mal kurz mit.
Und da hat er
mir einen Brief in die Hand gedrückt,
wo drinne stand, nee, Moment, Moment.
Er hat erst mal angefangen zu sagen,
er hat erst mal gesagt, so, hey, ich hab dein Video geguckt.
Und, ähm, so nach dem Motto,
ja, was ich, ja,
er ist auch super zufrieden und, und
in dem Video hat er ja noch mal quasi dann auch gehört,
was ich alles machen würde.
Und dann hat er mir einen Briefumschlag in die Hand gedrückt,
dass ich jetzt, ähm,
quasi in eine
Gehaltsgruppe, Tarifgehaltsgruppe
höher eingestuft werde seit diesem
Monat. Das hat mich echt, er hat
mich auch überrascht, ja. Ich hab ja,
ich hab ja sogar noch im Video gesagt,
ähm, ich muss mein, ich muss mein Chef mal wieder
nerven wegen mehr Kohle.
Und jetzt bin ich Gehaltsgruppe
sechs. Ich glaub, ich glaub
neun gibt's. Das ist nice.
Gibt's jetzt glaub,
gibt's jetzt, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie viel mehr Geld es gibt, ehrlich gesagt.
Es gibt, wir haben ja letztens im Stream geguckt,
VGS Tarifvertrag.
Ich kann noch mal gucken, ich kann euch
sagen, wie viel mehr Geld es gibt.
Nee.
Tarifvertrag.
Versicherung.
Boah, vorher war ich fünf.
Vorher war ich fünf mit Bonus.
Und jetzt bin ich,
und jetzt bin ich, ähm,
sechs.
Ich bin hier unten, weil ich schon
vierzehn Jahre dabei bin.
Und das mal
vierzehn, vierzehn Monatsgehälter.
Das heißt,
okay,
da kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Das wäre, wenn ich fünf Tage die Woche arbeite, wohlgemerkt.
Ich arbeite ja keine fünf Tage die Woche.
Ja, dazu kommt noch ein bisschen Sonderleistung
und Gedöns.
Aber das ist doch cool. Also ich würd mal sagen,
so über den Daumen gepeilt sind es 300 Euro im Monat mehr.
Ungefähr.
35 Stunden? Nee, 30 Stunden.
Normalerweise, normalerweise
müsste ich, ähm,
37,
85 oder so
arbeiten. Und ich arbeite
ja nur vier Tage die Woche, also
quasi 30 Stunden.
Ich finde, das ist auch ein ganz gutes
Pensum,
ja. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das
ausgehalten habe früher
tatsächlich da fünf Tage die Woche
zu arbeiten. Und nebenbei
YouTube Zeugs zu machen.
Mein Vertrag,
nee, mein Vertrag war für 37,
85 Stunden.
Aber den haben wir umgestellt auf
irgendwie
30,5 oder so.
Äh, das hab ich, äh,
gera-
ravengeard6,
ähm, das hab ich letzten Sonntag schon
erzählt.
Weil die Leute immer gefragt haben.
Und vier Tage ist top. Ich hab mir sogar
letztens schon überlegt, ob ich nicht
einfach, weil ich krieg in letzter Zeit
so viele Sellout-Angebote auf,
per Mail auch, ja.
Ähm, so viele Sellout-Angebote,
die echt
attraktiv sind. Sowas wie
Ghost Recon zum Beispiel.
Und ich hab mir so gedacht,
ich hab's ja auch schon auf Twitter gepostet,
ich hab mir so gedacht,
ich mein, ich hab, ich hab immer
relativ wenig Sellout gemacht, ja.
Ich hab eigentlich außer für
Sachen, so wie Elgato und so, was ich halt
selbst benutze, hab ich eigentlich nie Sellout gemacht.
Und letztens, so morgens,
so scheiß morgens, als ich aufgestanden bin,
ähm, und im Bad gesessen
hab, hab dann meistens noch
so zehn Minuten Zeit, da bleib ich halt im Bad sitzen,
mach irgendwie die Heizung an, Lüfter an und
guck ein bisschen auf dem Handy rum.
Und da ist mir eingefallen, da hab ich gesagt, Max,
warum machst du nicht einfach mehr Sellout?
Weil,
mal ganz ehrlich,
als würde Manuel Neuer
Cola
geil finden.
Dankeschön, Nico CS, Stufe 1,
abonniert, zwei Monate.
Huge IQ, plus 50.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was ich mein?
Oder als würde, ähm,
irgendwas gibt's ja noch für Sportler,
die, die Werbung machen.
Bleiben wir mal bei Manuel Neuer, als findet der Cola
so geil, der findet Cola im Werbespot
geil, weil er Cola für kriegt.
Dann hab ich mir gedacht, warum mach ich das nicht einfach?
Die Angebote sind gut, ja,
es gibt jetzt was für Ghost Recon gab's,
es gibt was für irgendwie so ein komisches,
so ein komisches, äh,
Mobile MMO, es gibt was für, für,
ja gut, was es immer gibt, es sind
diese ganze Wargaming-Geschichten,
und
dann häng ich mir als, genau,
Tipico, ja, sowas, also,
hab ich mir gedacht, okay, warum,
warum eigentlich nicht? Und zwar werd ich
das so machen,
bisher hab ich meine Sellouts ja
immer versucht, so ein bisschen,
in, bisschen so in meinen Style
von den, von den Videos einzubinden, ja, also ich hab
bei dem Ghost Recon Video gesagt, so, ey, ich denke,
das ist vielleicht was für Leute, die Koop spielen wollen,
und, ähm,
ein bisschen so, wie, wie ich normalerweise
auch ein Video machen würde, ohne Sellout.
So, und ich
hab mir überlegt, ich werd das bei den, bei den, bei den
Sellout-Videos einfach so machen,
ich werd sagen am Anfang, hey, das ist Werbung,
oder aber im Video sagen, hey, es ist Werbung,
und dann halt kurz mal ne Minute,
oder ne 30 Sekunden erzählen,
äh, warum,
warum man sich irgendwas angucken soll, halt, was die
Marketing-Sachen sagen. Ich werde nicht
sagen, dass das meiner Meinung nach
toll ist, oder dass ich davon überzeugt
bin, oder so, ich werd einfach nur sagen, Jungs,
Werbung,
und dann ein paar schöne Marketing-Sprüche machen,
was ihnen halt so gefällt.
Ich mein, guckt euch das beispielsweise
an, äh,
Linus Tech Tips macht das,
ähm, ElectroWoo macht das, das macht das,
machen sau viele Channels,
und da ist eigentlich, finde ich, heutzutage überhaupt
nichts dagegen einzuwenden,
solange man das halt nicht
so verkauft,
als wäre es, ähm,
deine eigene Überzeugung, weißt du, ja,
ich finde, das finde ich ist das Verwerfliche, falls
da, wenn das Leute machen, das machen Beauty-Channels
zum Beispiel ganz gerne, so, mein Gott, ich
habe heute zufällig dieses tolle Parfüm
gefunden, oh, da bin ich ja so glücklich, da ich das
gefunden hab, ey, du hast das nicht gefunden, die haben
mir das geschickt und 50k gegeben, um das zu
bewerben. Das ist ne
Sache, die finde ich verwerflich, aber sich hinzustellen
und sagen, Jungs, Werbung,
äh, das ist das neue
MMO, bla bla bla, ihr könnt hier super
toll leveln und es ist das
schönste Mobile-MMO aller Zeiten,
und fertig,
ja, das ist easy
sellout, easy life,
ähm, und
dann weiß auch jeder, dass
das jetzt nicht irgendwie meine persönliche, wenn ich das
so sage, dass das meine persönliche Überzeugung ist,
sondern das wird einfach
runter, äh, eingebaut,
und, und
halt Werbung erzählen,
weil man sollte es bei Games, was halbwegs gut ist,
ganz ehrlich,
umso beschissener die Games, umso mehr Kohle
gibt's dafür. Werbung für
Coin Master, na gut, also irgendwann
ist auch mal ne, ne, ne Grenze
unterschritten, also Coin Master Werbung
ist ja schon
ziemlich beknackt, aber ganz ehrlich,
wenn einer zu mir
ankommen würde und sagt, Max, ich geb dir 50k, mach
Coin Master Werbung,
warum nicht? Wird doch, aber nicht,
so wie die anderen Coin Master Werbung gemacht
haben. Die haben ja quasi ihre persönliche,
die haben es ja so verkauft, als wäre es ihre
persönliche Überzeugung, dass Coin Master geil ist.
Die haben quasi versucht, ähm,
in ihrer eigenen, das so
anzusprechen, die Leute,
dass sie quasi sagen, oh ja, ich finde
Coin Master ist ein tolles Spiel, so
nach dem Motto.
Hat er gerade mein Dorf angegriffen?
Das finde ich beknackt.
Aber wenn man sagt,
ähm, so nach dem Motto,
dieses Video ist gesponsert,
von irgendwie,
äh, Hörbuch, Hörbuch-Plattform
XY. Hier könnt ihr immer
die neuesten Hörbücher zu den aktuellen
Bestsellern und von den besten
Sprechern ever anhören.
Und, äh, mit dem MaxFPS
Promo-Code kriegt ihr auch,
keine Ahnung, äh,
zwei Bücher umsonst. Der Link ist in der Beschreibung.
Was ist denn dabei?
Da ist doch, ist doch
eigentlich, das ist, das ist mir morgens
gedämmert, als ich zum Klo gesessen habe. Da ist doch eigentlich überhaupt nichts
dabei. Das ist, das, das
checkt jeder, dass das Werbung ist.
Das sind keine
irgendwie verwerflichen
Dinger, ja?
Ähm, das ist jetzt nicht, dass ich da irgendwie
ja irgendwelche Casinos oder
oder Glücksspiel-Seiten
oder, oder Abzocke,
äh, Skin-Seiten oder
so bewerbe, sondern ganz normales
Zeug, was ich halt in den Videos
platzieren will. Na, meiner Meinung nach
sollte man nichts bewerben, was man nicht selbst davon
überzeugt ist.
Ja, kann man, kann man so sehen, aber ich bin mittlerweile
zu dem Schluss gekommen, das dachte
ich auch immer, aber
ich finde es überhaupt nicht verwerflich,
solange man nicht den Leuten quasi
verkaufen möchte,
dass es eben, dass man das Video
jetzt irgendwie macht, weil man so überzeugt davon
ist. Da sagt man, ja, ich bekomme dafür
aber vielleicht Geld, aber trotzdem, ich hätte
das Video auch so gemacht, weil es ist so ein tolles Produkt.
Das finde ich
beknackt. Aber einfach nur sagen, hey, das
Video wird gesponsert von XY und dieser
Dienst, da könnt ihr das und das und das machen,
das checkt doch
jeder. Und wenn es halt, wenn es
normale Dienste sind,
da denke ich, ist da überhaupt nichts dagegen
zu sagen. Nicht so, naja,
es kommt drauf an. Also wenn man
ein komplettes
Promotion-Video macht, wie jetzt
beispielsweise zu Ghostreken oder
irgendwas anderes, das wollen die
in der Regel sehen,
aber es geht mir bei dieser
Sache auch nicht um irgendwelche komplette Promotion-Videos,
sondern um Sachen, die ich
einfach einbauen kann,
in normale Videos. Guckt euch das mal
Linus Tech Tips zum Beispiel an, er macht das genauso.
Der macht seine
Videos und dann
erwähnt er in dem Video immer 30-45
Sekunden irgendeinen
Hardware-Software-
Serviceanbieter. Und
das sind ja in der Regel auch keine Scamprodukte
oder so, die er
bewirbt,
aber da erwartet ja auch keiner,
dass er die alle persönlich kennt und unter die Lupe
genommen hat. Ja, wenn das auf den ersten Blick
seriös aussieht,
dann denke ich, kann man das
auch machen. Ich würde auch keine Casinos
oder Coinmaster oder
keine Ahnung, Skintrading-Seiten
oder so machen. Also irgendwas, was nach Scam aussieht.
Aber mal angenommen,
es kommt jetzt irgendein Anbieter
von Energydrinks
oder von Gaming
Booster oder irgendwas,
keine Ahnung. Ja, wenn er jetzt zu mir kommt
und sagt, Max, was hältst du denn davon?
Willst du nicht ein paar Mal
das bei uns in die Videos
einbauen? Da sehe ich da
eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem mehr mittlerweile drin.
Wenn ich dann sage, hey, das Video ist gesponsert
von Gaming Booster XY,
bestes Gaming
Getränk,
weil, keine Ahnung, super viel
Vitamin C drin ist. Und wenn
ihr mehr wissen wollt, dann guckt mal im Link unten vorbei.
Da erkennt jeder sofort,
dass das Werbung ist. Das ist
klipp und klar
dann Werbung. Und das
bringt halt richtig was.
Da wird übrigens so viel geschwätzt, dass ich das eine Stück Pütter
nicht mal komplett gefunden habe.
Verwendest du das Github-Tool?
Was? Welches?
So, du meinst, ob ich generell Github verwende?
Genau, Schneeflöckchen.
Oder Schneevlockchen.
Das sehe ich auch so. Nur weil man was selbst nicht ausprobiert hat,
heißt das ja nicht, dass es automatisch Scam ist,
im Endeffekt. Achso, ne,
das hat einer gerade im Chat
gefragt, ob ich das kenne.
Sag mal was zum Deep Loader. Ich habe es noch nie verwendet.
Das hat mich noch gerade einer im Chat gefragt.
Aber das, was ich da so lese, klingt eigentlich nach einer
sinnvollen Lösung.
Vor allem ist Candy Crush da endlich weg.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, dann hast du
dein gesamtes YouTube-Geld noch nicht mal
angefasst. Ja, so gut wie nicht.
Das einzige, was ich von meinem YouTube-Geld gemacht
habe bisher, ist, ich habe
zwei Leuten einen Privatkredit gegeben.
Mit...
Und ich muss sagen, das war nicht meine Idee.
Mit fast schon unverschämt hohen Zinsen.
Das war eben nicht meine Idee. Das haben die vorgeschlagen.
Ich habe gesagt, Leute, ich habe echt
schlechtes Gewissen, wenn ich euch die Kohle für
die Geschichten gebe, ja.
Aber die haben halt
Kohle gebraucht.
Weil ich die kenne.
Und ich weiß, dass ich das auch wiederkriege.
Okay, dann mache ich das.
Weil besser, als dass es rumliegt.
Sag mal, was für eine Core-Version benutzt du eigentlich
mit der Tastmutter?
Top Basic?
Was da drauf ist auf der Steckdosenleiste.
Was würdest du für Projekte
neben dem IT-Studium empfehlen, um den Lebenslauf
zu pimpen?
Meinst du jetzt Software-Entwicklungstechnisch?
Dann würde ich
irgendwas empfehlen.
Also wenn du das wirklich nur dafür machst,
dass es gut aussieht,
dann würde ich irgendwas
empfehlen. Nicht, was du geil
findest. Also, es wäre
natürlich schön, wenn man das verbinden kann.
Aber nicht nur
was, was du geil findest, sondern irgendwas, was ein bisschen
Business,
was bei den ganzen Firmen angesagt ist.
Zum Beispiel,
mach irgendeine
Sache auf
Java-Basis.
Irgendwas Enterprise-mäßiges.
Keine Ahnung.
Inventarverwaltung
oder so.
Und verwende dafür die Tools,
wo du denkst,
dass das Enterprise-technisch angesagt ist.
Das muss nichts Sinnvolles sein.
Das muss denen zeigen,
du kannst das
und es ist irgendwie auch Techniken,
die die auch verwenden.
Weil da muss man auch ehrlich sagen,
ich sag ja immer, wenn mich die Leute fragen,
so hier auch im Stream,
was man zum Einstieg fürs Programmieren
machen sollte.
Da sag ich immer,
mach was oder such dir was raus,
was du machen willst,
wo du schon quasi Ideen hast, was du umsetzen willst
oder irgendwas, was dich nervt, wo du selbst was programmieren willst,
weil dich andere Software nervt.
Und dann such dir die passenden Sprachen und Technologien
dafür raus.
Aber wenn du mich jetzt fragst, was soll ich programmieren,
dass es in meinem Lebenslauf
gut aussieht, dann muss man natürlich Tools
nehmen, die
Business-mäßig etabliert sind.
Und da ist es natürlich gut, wenn du dich mit Java auskennst,
wenn du dich mit, wie heißt der
Maven-Nachfolger, ich bin da nicht so drin,
was Java angeht, mit irgendwelchen
Java-Buildtools auskennst, mit irgendwelchen
Java-Repo-Geschichten auskennst,
ist nicht verkehrt. Ich mein, ich würd's im Leben nicht
mit der Kneifzange oder den
Isolierhandschuhen angreifen.
And Cradle, Cradle mein ich,
ich glaub Cradle ist es.
Ich kenn mich ja nicht so aus.
Java, klar, Java ist
Business-technisch die meistverbreiteste
Programmiersprache überhaupt.
Die ganzen Business-Anwendungen
sind wieder in Java.
Oder wenn es Finanzzeug ist und noch
älter, dann sind die in Coborn.
Ja, Java ist nicht für alt.
Bloodpack, ich weiß
es nicht. Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht.
Das, was Tuya Convert
standardmäßig mitliefert,
kannst du mal nachgucken.
Ich weiß es nicht. Du bist noch in der
Kot-Kategorie. Ich weiß, wir spielen auch gleich
weiter. Der Nico hat auch was
Interessantes gesagt. Natürlich ist es
auch nicht schlecht, je nachdem
für welche Business-Sachen
du was machen willst, wenn du ein bisschen
Buzzword-Bingo machst.
Also, wenn du irgendeinen
irgendeinen Bot,
irgendeine Bot-AI programmierst
und das auf Docker laufen
lässt oder noch besser auf Kubernetes,
nicht laufen lassen, du kannst ja bloß schreiben, dass es
dafür gedacht ist. Vollkommen egal, ob das
wirklich da drauf dann bei dir läuft.
Und wenn du dann auch Blockchain
dabei schreibst, dann ist ja alles,
dann flippen sie aus.
Vollkommen egal, ob Kubernetes im Heimnetzwerk
oder überhaupt Kubernetes. Schreib's
dabei. Schreib dabei,
dass deine Software
optimiert ist, in Kubernetes zu laufen.
Vollkommen egal, was das eigentlich jetzt
genau heißen soll. Das ist ein schönes
Buzzword, wo gerade viele drauf gucken,
Kubernetes. Oder Azure.
Sag, es ist
quasi
One-Click-Deployment für
Kubernetes und Azure.
Das klingt gut.
One-Click
Deployment.
Das ist so easy. One-Click-Deployment.
Azure und Kubernetes.
Dann sagen die alle, alter, boah, ist der modern.
Da finden sie es geil.
Ja.
Ja, ja. Nee, das machen
ähm,
das machen nicht Leute, die sich in der IT auskennen.
Das machen meistens
Personal-Leute, die sich die Leute, also die
zuerst mal
quasi die Sachen
in die Finger kriegen.
Da fahren Personal-Leute
oder irgendwelche
Leute, die zwar in der IT sind,
aber dort irgendwelche
Management-Funktionen haben, die von der Technik keine
Ahnung haben. Und
die
finden das geil, wenn da Blockchain
drinsteht, Kubernetes und Azure.
Das ist Wahnsinn. Das finden die geil.
Weil, man muss sich auch mal überlegen,
dass viele große Unternehmen ja gar nicht mehr so diese
klassische Bewerbungsgeschichte
machen.
Ähm, dass du dich direkt bei denen bewirbst.
Sondern, die schreiben
das irgendwo aus, über irgendeine
Zwischenfirma,
die das quasi schon vorfiltert
und voraufbereitet.
Und die haben überhaupt
keine Ahnung, was da eigentlich die Sache ist.
Die kriegen bloß gesagt,
wir brauchen Leute
mit Cloud-Erfahrung,
mit Kubernetes-Erfahrung,
mit Ansible-Erfahrung,
mit Docker-Erfahrung, mit sonst was.
Und wenn das dann halt
nicht da ist, dann sagen die, oh ne, ne, das passt dafür nicht.
Du kannst BWL ja
ziemlich gut vermeiden, wenn du in den IT-Bereich
gehst. Allerdings erst, wenn du drinnen bist.
Davor sind halt irgendwelche
Personaltypen, meistens.
Bei größeren Läden, ja. Wenn du jetzt natürlich
bei kleineren Firmen nicht bist, die das noch selbst machen,
dann sieht das anders aus.
Ich find's immer lustig,
wenn, ähm,
Personalleute, beziehungsweise
ähm, Business,
Business-BWL-Leute,
entscheiden wollen,
ob jemand
technisch was kann oder nicht.
Die achten wirklich drauf,
ob Leute einen Anzug anhaben
und sowas. Da hab ich ja, da hab ich
auch schon mal mit, da hab ich gesagt, Leute,
das hat doch überhaupt
nix zu sagen. Der Typ,
der kennt sich doppelt so gut aus, wahrscheinlich,
wie alle anderen, die heute
den ganzen Tag da hattet, aber
der hatte halt keinen Anzug an. Ja und?
Wo ist das Problem?
Wenn du einen Tealer mit Anzug suchst,
dann musst du dich nicht wundern,
wenn du keine gescheiten findest.
Also wer wirklich sagt, bei uns ist Anzugpflicht,
der findet keine gescheiten Leute.
Der GIF legt das Aussehen heiß, damit du nicht das Anzug anziehen musst.
Ich seh auch keinen Anzug an und seh nicht aus,
wie der letzte Kackpenner.
Oder vielleicht doch.
Aus Sicht von irgendwelchen, äh,
Reimfrisur, ähm, Louis Vuitton
Anzug Leuten, seh ich wahrscheinlich
schon aus, wie der letzte Penner, weil ich das nicht anhabe.
Aber, ansonsten
würde ich mal eher sagen, sieht sich da ganz normal aus.
Nee, aber,
also wirklich,
wenn man nach IT Leuten sucht, die was taugen,
ähm, mal ganz ehrlich Leute,
geht mal auf den, auf den
auf den YouTube Channel
und guckt euch
Vorträge vom CCC an.
Oder guckt euch mal da die Leute an.
Das sind teilweise
mit
mit die besten Leute,
die wir in Deutschland so haben, in manchen Bereichen. Nicht alle,
aber da sind schon gute Leute dabei.
Die sehen alle nicht business-
like aus, ja.
Die sehen überhaupt nicht business-style aus, die Typen.
Aber die können was.
Dementsprechend, so sehen halt
Leute aus, die technisch was können.
Und
nicht vorne rum
da, ähm,
auf den ersten Blick halt vielleicht so wirken,
im Anzug als, als sind's es,
ja. Und der Typ, der
in Jogginghose Bandshot kam, hat
die Ausbildung bekommen. Ja, das ist
natürlich nur so, wenn die Leute, wenn die Firmen
das selber noch machen.
Äh, wenn du da über irgendwelche
reinen Personaldinger erst mal durch musstest,
dann wird's schwierig. Also fürs
Bewerbungsgespräch ist ein Anzug schon ein Muss.
Ich hatte noch keine
Bewerbungsgespräch in Anzug an.
Ich hatte eine ordentliche Hose an und
ein Hemd.
Ich hatte noch nie einen Anzug an.
Also gehen tut das schon.
Ihh, äh,
was ist das?
Ich hab grad ein Stück Traube gegessen und das war übelst aufgeplatzt.
Da war wahrscheinlich ein Wurm drin oder so.
Ähm.
Doch, ich hab nen Anzug.
Ich hab nen
Anzug, aber
da pass ich nicht mehr rein.
Den Anzug hab ich noch aus Zeiten,
da hab ich 65 Kilo gewonnen.
Konnte, keine Ahnung,
10 Kilometer schwimmen und
gar, was weiß ich, 20 Kilometer
rennen oder so.
Und war relativ fit.
Aus der Zeit ist
der Anzug. Wenn ich das
heute anziehen würde, dann wäre
das ein RIP.
So, also ich hab die Pizza fertig, Leute.
Können weiterspielen.
Einzige Problem ist,
ich hab noch nen Brötchen
jetzt geholt hier. So, Brötchen mit
bisschen Schokolade drauf.
Hätte ich gern ein bisschen Süßkram, wär nicht verkehrt.
Aber ich glaube, ich spiel erstmal
weiter, oder?
Oh, kann ich noch 5 Minuten essen
oder soll ich weiterspielen?
Aber wir sind ja grade nice,
nice am schwätzen eigentlich. Essen ist wichtig.
Naja, aber, ist nicht so, dass ich da
von der, vom Fleisch falle.
Ja, Essen. Na, aber still, ist okay.
Na gut, dann ess ich weiter.
Ähm...
Hast du Erfahrung mit Tätowierungen in der IT?
Vor allem als AE. Juckt das jemand?
Keine Ahnung.
Jetzt bei den meisten siehst du's nicht, ja?
Ähm...
Außer, sie haben ein T-Shirt und am Arm was.
Ja, doch. Doch, klar.
Bei uns hat einer eins.
Aber allein, weil ich deswegen so lange drüber
nachdenken muss, ähm...
Juckt das zumindest bei uns.
Kein großartig. Wahrscheinlich sieht's
ein bisschen anders aus, wenn du halt quasi komplett
komplett auch im Gesicht und so zu bist.
Keine Ahnung, da werden dann die Leute erstmal dich ein bisschen komisch angucken.
Musst du natürlich irgendwie davon überzeugen,
dass das nix auszusagen hat, was schwierig
sein kann. Äh, Tommy,
das gibt's auch. Keine Frage.
Keine, keine Frage.
Es gibt, es gibt so Leute,
die der Meinung sind, ähm...
Ohne Anzug bist du nicht kompetent.
Das ist aber...
Ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher, ob das rechtlich überhaupt okay ist.
Jemand heimzuschicken, weil er
Jeans und T-Shirt anhat.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wenn man IT-Consulting macht...
Ja gut, IT-Consulting hört sich ja auch nur
vom Namen her so an, als muss man dafür was können.
Ähm...
IT-Consulting bedeutet
erste Mal...
Ich sag nicht immer,
relativ banale Dinge gut verkaufen zu können.
Dass man dann auch ein paar Leute
haben muss, die was können.
Je nachdem, zu was man consultet wird.
Was anderes.
Aber Consulting geht's ja erst mal
darum, dass du einen guten Eindruck machst
bei Nicht-Technikern.
Und einen guten Eindruck
bei Nicht-Technikern,
weil ich meine, du kommst als IT-Consultant ja nicht
zu Leuten, die sich mit Technik auskennen.
Wenn du Glück hast, sitzt da mal einer dabei.
Du kommst als IT-Consultant zum, keine Ahnung, zum Vorstand,
zum Chef, zum sonst was.
Und das sind natürlich Leute, für die ist
Anzug gleich Kompetenz.
Weil die das aus ihrer eigenen Welt kennen.
Es kennt ja jeder meistens,
meistens leider nur seine eigene Welt.
Machst du noch Netzwerk-Videos?
Klar.
Hab ich doch als letztes VPN-Video gemacht.
Wie kann man sich... Ich hab keine Pizza.
Ich hab zwei Stück Pizza gegessen.
Früher 65 Kilo
und nur eine Pizza.
Früher hab ich das auch gegessen.
Früher hab ich den ganzen Tag im Büro gesessen,
vor dem Rechner.
Hattest du eigentlich beim Download mit dem
Battle.net Launcher und Schwankungen beim Download
mittlerweile... Nö, es ging eigentlich.
Wenn irgendwann ein Face-Reveal
kommt, dann im Anzug. Garantiert nicht.
Also sollte ich mal
Face-Reveal machen,
hab ich mir schon überlegt, da zieh ich mir wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich zieh ich mir irgendwie ein
Iron Maiden-T-Shirt an oder sowas.
Snizzle, Wizzle, also das funktioniert bei mir ziemlich gut.
Aber es hat Framedrops.
So, ich atme jetzt kurz
das Brötchen ein.
Ich glaub ich hab 35% CPU-Auslastung
oder so. Fuck.
Das hab ich in meinem Task Manager gemacht.
Kann man demnächst
sagen, dass der... Ja, always on top.
47%.
48%.
Irgendwie so.
Schneidermission, ja, Schneidermission.
Wir schneiden auch weiter nach dem Brötchen.
Doch, doch, Wirtschaftsinformatiker
sind auch schon gefragt.
Wobei du höchst
wahrscheinlich mehr Wirtschaft als Informatik machen wirst.
Ah, das kommt auch ein bisschen auf dich an.
Das ist ja ein 8700
K. Übertaktet auf 5,1
Gigahertz.
Ich sag doch
die CPU, deswegen hab ich mich vorhin so
aufgeregt, dass es geruckelt hat.
Das ist CPU-technisch immer noch eine der
schnellsten Desktop-CPUs, die du überhaupt haben kannst.
Also vor allem in übertakteter
Form. Ja, Razer
ist nicht für jeden was.
Wir haben auch ein paar, die vorher
Informatik versucht haben zu studieren.
Äh, Fiese ist Fachinformatiker Systemintegration.
Was hältst
du von IT-Security-Engineers?
Es kommt auf
den oder die oder
das
äh, IT-Security-Engineer an.
Da kann ich, ach so.
Von dem Beruf.
Ähm, keine Ahnung.
Das ist wieder so ein
so ein Begriff,
wo wahrscheinlich jeder ein bisschen was anderes reininterpretiert.
Letztens haben sie mich
übelst verwirrt, ne.
Ich habe mal irgendeinen Speedrun-Stream gesehen
und da stand oben
in der Ecke der Name des
Runners.
Da stand dann sowas, da stand dann sowas
drinne, ähm, wie, keine Ahnung.
Max Runner Pro.
Das war dann, das ist jetzt ausgedachter
Name, ne. War der Name vom Runner
und dahinter
haben sie in Klammern das Geschlecht immer reingeschrieben,
weil es ja mittlerweile so
ist, dass du nicht mehr anhand der Stimme
wirklich eindeutig
erkennen kannst, als was
jemand bezeichnet werden möchte.
Und das hat mich verwirrt. Da stand das hier drinne.
They.
Als Geschlecht.
Da habe ich mir gedacht.
Was
ist das? Ich habe es nicht kapiert.
Ernsthaft.
Ich will in so keinen Flame.
Ich verstehe es bloß nicht.
Ne, sorry.
Stimmt nicht. Stimmt nicht.
Verstand. Ich glaube es stand.
Ich glaube es stand He-Say drinne.
Was? Was ist das?
Hat er Multi-Persönlichkeiten?
Oder? Und vor allem
ich glaube es ist
grammatikalisch noch
überhaupt keine
Form erfunden worden,
die man
dafür verwenden kann.
Also ich habe echt keine Ahnung.
Das hat mich hochgradig verwirrt.
Ja, wenn da, ähm,
was steht bei Mädels immer?
She, her drinne steht. Ok.
Verstehe ich. Sie ist weiblich
und man sagt halt sie.
Hör!
Aber was ist?
Er möchte nur, genau.
Er möchte nur so, eure durchlaucht wahrscheinlich.
Schau dir das an, Max.
Oh, das.
Ja.
Der Typ, den kenne ich.
Der ist ja ganz, der ist ja bei den
Amis ganz
vorne mit dabei, wenn es um solche Themen geht.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
es ist nicht
unlogisch, was er erzählt an vielen Stellen.
Ähm.
Er ist vielleicht ein bisschen,
ja, wie soll ich sagen, in manchen Stellen
ein bisschen zu sehr auf dem Offensichtlichen rumgeritten.
Aber
es ist nicht, es ist nicht unlogisch.
Es hat schon Hand und Fuß, was er von sich gibt.
Max, wenn du jetzt weitermachst, kriegst du ein Twitch-Band.
Warum?
Ich habe, ich verstehe bloß nicht, was es heißen soll.
Wo kam die Ami von,
von meinem Overlay-Tool?
Ich kann auch Kokona sagen.
Max, switch auf Mixer.
Genau. Ninja. Shroud.
Die logische Konsequenz.
Die logische Konsequenz, ja.
Er ist Ninja, dann Shroud,
dann Wubblos.
Spielt ihr alles in der gleichen
Liga, ja?
Ja, macOS so gut wie keine Erfahrung.
Bis jetzt
ist es ein Roll-Cut, Clips, Grafik
finde ich cool.
Der Aufbau hier auch, aber die Kampagne ist bis jetzt ein bisschen langweilig.
Kein Wubblos,
weil ich den Account mal erstellt habe.
Ich glaube,
ich habe den Account mal erstellt.
Sogar vom Smartphone,
weil ich mal irgendwas im Chat schreiben wollte
und ich den Account nie zum Streamen gedacht habe.
Wir haben gerade nachgeguckt,
bei mir läuft die CPU 47%
ingame.
Wohlgemerkt Singleplayer-Kampagne.
Warum kein Name-Change?
Weil ich das jetzt schon so etabliert habe,
dass die Leute, die da wären, verwirrt wären,
warum es auf einmal anders heißt.
Proxy im Heimnetz, gute Idee.
Kommt immer drauf an, für was.
Musst du in meinem Studium
zwischen VBA-Programmierung und Python
wählen? Was würdest du empfehlen?
VBA, Alter, hör mal auf.
VBA.
2019.
VBA ist Visual Basic
for Applications.
Kannst du Excel-Makros programmieren.
Mit VBA nicht mehr benutzt,
ja doch.
Aber besser macht es auch nicht.
So, fertig gefordert.
Hat jetzt nur 3 Stunden gedauert.
Weiter geht's.
Fette Wurst.
Wenn du das irgendwie schaffst,
per Twitch Private Message zu übertragen,
dann schon.
Was gab's denn? 2 Stücke Pizza und Brötchen.
Musik aus.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, was das
Overwatch-Rebellen-Grill
in der Code-Campagne weiter so treibt.
So.
Weiter geht's.
Was jetzt angesagt? Schleimermission.
Lautstärke passt.
Ich hab gerade in meiner Ausbildung das Thema
IT-Kryptographie. Echt abgefahrener
Shit.
Das einzige, was du dir am Anfang
merken musst, wenn es um das Thema
Kryptographie bzw. Verschlüsselung
geht, ist, also ein ganz wichtiger
Grundsatz.
Du musst wissen können,
wie ein
Verfahren funktioniert
und es trotzdem nicht knacken können. Dann ist es gut.
Also du musst wissen, wie
was funktioniert und mit diesem Wissen
darfst du trotzdem nicht in der Lage sein,
was zu entchlüsseln, ohne dass du Entschlüssel hast.
Okay, ich bin wieder Alex und ich soll
scopen.
Welche Road?
Ach, das da.
Wohin soll ich scopen? Dahin.
Got it.
Now adjust your magnification.
Increase your zoom, Alex.
Ah, da ist er. On it, Commander.
How formal.
Alif.
Stay with him and you'll see my team near the road.
Yep, I see him.
They'll support us when we attack
the Al-Qatala convoy.
Aya, hittilna hadafjin bilbas.
Boomer gameplay?
Naja, mal ernsthaft, Loki.
Das ist kein Boomer gameplay, das ist eindeutig
Zoomer gameplay gerade. Oder willst du was anderes behaupten?
Adjust for distance. Each one is 200 meters.
Also das ist ja wohl mal mehr
Zoomer, als Zoomer sein kann.
Hatemu, Tavjir.
The target is 400 meters away.
Aim two notches above it.
Miss.
Wow.
Geht's.
She speaks for you, Alex.
My brother, your biggest fan.
Let's try another target, at a different range.
So, wenn wo er weggeht.
There's a blue house in the distance. Can you see it?
Komm, ist doch so.
Sackt.
It's a one-story blue house to the west.
What?
Blue house, past the hill.
Ach, da hinten.
There's fruit on the icebox.
Die F.
Die soll auf die Melone.
Range is 600 meters.
Lower, to the left.
Damn.
Touch me back one time.
I heard that.
You're high on. Pay attention, boys.
You should be dialed in now.
Remember, use the environment to your advantage.
Flags for wind direction, landmarks for distance.
Understood.
Now, watch the highway for activity.
They won't be long now.
Surfer's come.
Nothing but the wind.
I got something.
By that moving oil pump.
What?
What? Ach, da hinten.
Just some stray dogs.
Ich hab's noch nicht mal gesehen.
She's scanning the road. The wolf will be here soon.
Oh, ich weiß mal,
ob die Furcht hingucken soll.
Da war's.
Rechts.
Ich hab' sie nicht gesehen.
Mach sie.
Lade hegemo.
Der Flotter der Fahrt.
Rechts.
Könnte der Wolf sein oder sein Mann sein.
Sieht aus, als hätten wir endlich etwas.
Es ist ganz geschneit.
Aber, das ist schon ziemlich Noob-Style,
Hardscope.
So gewinnst du, also so kannst du keine Sniper-Montage machen.
Ali, schei von G.
Ich bin auf dem Ruf, Alex.
Du, auf dem Ruf.
Ja, ich sehe ihn.
Ich sehe den Wind.
So, hä?
So?
Bam.
Rechts.
Den hab' ich überhaupt nicht getroffen.
Ali, jalla Ruhe.
Khadir ist ressourcful.
Er hat sie für den Wolfs-Mann gesetzt.
Alex.
Warum ist er nicht in der Fahrt?
Das Tötchen des Wolfs garantiert uns nicht, dass wir Gas verloren haben.
Das ist wahr.
Was passiert, wenn du sie nicht findest?
Ich muss hinереuchen.
Ich muss.
Da dazu l pesten.
Ah, der ist in einem guten Game.
Ne, vielleicht ein Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Big Brain.
Range, könnte die Easy Collateral Wall bangen, alle drei auf einmal.
Können dann nicht außen rum fahren.
Die müssen jetzt wirklich in dem einen Auto da warten, oder was?
Bam.
Okay, das hat echt ein bisschen was Morhul-artiges.
Dann sind sie gescoped.
Resident Sleeper-Vision.
Warte, Jeff, ich seh die überhaupt nicht.
Bam.
Back.
Oh, es lebt.
Oh, fuck.
Was ist da los?
Man kann den Köpfe abschießen.
Ja, ja.
Alter, gut.
Was?
What? Wie kommt der da hin?
Alter, das Game.
Das hat echt...
jetzt lässt die gegner gerne im laufen schießen was soll ich eigentlich machen
irgendwas irgendwas eliminate
marisch easy, überhaupt kein problem
sag
entschreckt
wo
oh ich sehs nicht
super greller twitch prime dankeschön
huge sub
du hast
was auch immer ich habe es nicht getroffen
aber ich hab's überhaupt nicht gekillt
was erzählt ihr mir da
ich war da überhaupt
nicht gekillt und was erzählt ihr mir da
ich hab's überhaupt nicht gekillt
Ich habe das überhaupt nicht getroffen und trotzdem hat es explodiert.
Das ist echt für die Noobs.
Good job Alex, voll vorbei geschossen, nice gemacht.
OP, OPs Spray and Pray Waffe.
Jawoll.
Oder das?
Er hat nämlich lieber eine SMG mit fast genau so viel Multipla- Warte mal, kann ich
das jetzt detonaten?
Das hat ja nichts gemacht oder was?
Willst du später noch Multipla, vielleicht, mal gucken wie viel Lust da ist, wann das
fertig ist.
Contact Captain Price.
Gibt es Korb?
Ja!
Captain Price is holding for you on the radio Alex.
Es gibt Spec Ops, Korb, Korb Missionen.
Muss ich dann mit dem Eax spielen, wenn ich die Kampagne durch habe.
Was?
Hier.
Echo 3-1 for Actual.
Alex.
Wie lange spielen der Maxon Single Pair?
Keine Ahnung.
Wow.
Seit, seit 16 Uhr oder so?
17 Uhr.
Copy.
On our way.
Au.
Sehr fair.
Aber gut, die haben gesagt, ich soll mich hinlegen, also lege ich mich hin.
Ich hab immer, ich hab, ich hab vergessen, es ist Call of Duty Kampagne, da musst du
exakt das machen, was dir gesagt wird, sonst kipp.
Copy.
On our way.
What?
Was?
Wo?
Alex, find that Sniper.
Da.
Perfekt.
Good kill, Alex.
Fischt.
Alcatara is regrouping across the highway.
This could be him.
Highway?
Seh nix.
We're at 600 meters, Alex.
Hit them.
What?
Ah, nein.
Perfekt.
Au, da war's mit dem Wind los.
Da muss ja.
Übelst um die Ecke schießen.
Oh, Air Support am Start.
Hätte ich jetzt auch nicht so viel rumschneibern müssen.
Die machen das doch eh.
Jo.
Hätte ich mit dem Schneibern auch sparen können.
Markov's Army will be here soon.
GWOZ.
Dreizehn Crusader.
Vier Monate.
Dankeschön.
Pock.
So.
Ja.
Little.
Male.
Ah.
Hopefully.
So.
MICHAEL!
XOXO.
H coins.
Ah!
Mann.
Da kommt was.
Rekt.
Noch mehr rekt.
Oh, drei Mann Collateral.
Ja, das hat es ja für die gelohnt, hä?
Mit dem LNV halb durch die Wüste fahren
und dann auf mich zurennen
und wanted werden.
Warhol 2019.
Okay.
Absolut schon dumme.
Aber richtig dumm.
Huge dumm ist die KI.
Wonka dumm.
Die Ecke kämpft mit einem Kamm.
Von wo?
Oh!
Wir müssen uns überhaupt nicht bewegen.
Das ist Easy-Bout, die kriegen ja nichts gebacken.
GZF.
Mal kurz hier warten, bis ich wieder gereckt bin.
Von hinten schießt was.
Ich seh's nicht da.
Das ist doch alles tot.
Das ist alles down.
Adir.
Adir, keine Panik.
Das ist alles tot.
Da, fuck, Alter.
GG Pure Ownage, Twitch Prime
und Serhii Dran, schon vier Monate.
Dankeschön für die Subs.
Fuck.
Mittlerweile ist der Chat heute ja schon bei,
bei, was weiß ich, mindestens 400 IQ.
4.000.
Mit Subs, die es heute gegeben hat.
Warum?
Das ergibt,
das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Die haben die, die haben,
die haben die komplette Kampagne Panik geschoben.
Vor dem Gas, was sie von den Russen geklaut haben.
Und jetzt sprengen sie das Gas einfach so random in die Luft.
Obwohl die Gegner sich übelst wegbashen lassen.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Adir, was ist das?
Was ist das für eine Maske?
Was?
Das ist ne Gasmaske oder hab ich ne Gasmaske?
Inside, okay.
Ich bin inside.
Jetzt!
Alter, 4 für die Gasmaske.
Bruder, muss Gas!
Hat dicho der Scheuer?
Doch, die Gegner waren dumm.
Wir hätten die einfach bashen sollen.
Ja, super.
Jetzt hat er das...
Oh Gott, ihr seid beknackt.
Das ist jetzt die Super-Twist gewesen, oder was?
Oh, ist das bescheuert.
Soll ich mich moven?
Ah, ich muss mich bewegen, okay.
Okay, jetzt wollen sie uns ein bisschen schocken.
Die haben, ich muss sagen, in dem Setting und generell in der Idee von der Kampagne,
steckt schon ein gewisses Potenzial drin.
Aber wirklich genutzt wird es nicht.
Also ich denke mal, dass wir jetzt Fahrer sind.
Fahrer als Kind oder sowas.
Wenn ein Fahrer ihr Jetpack bekommen hat.
Moment, wenn das Fahrer ist, ist das Anna, was neben uns gelegen hat?
Äh, by the way, haben wir eigentlich FPS-Drops?
Jetzt wieder?
Ne, jetzt haben wir keine FPS.
Ja, wir werden gerettet.
GG.
Wow.
Wow, KS.
Fuck.
Gott, ihr seid so...
Nein.
Uh!
Where is the deer.
We left him home.
To study.
Wie weit bist du denn in der Kampagne?
Keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich eine Stunde oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Wir waren übelst lahm.
Wanif!
I'm looking for resistance fighters.
Captain, go.
Now!
My gun is still at home.
I will help you, brother.
This way.
Papa, I'm scared.
Komm, die Russen und Westschnaube.
Das war klar.
Wahrscheinlich wollen sie uns jetzt beibringen, warum Farah so schlinkig auf die Russen ist.
Wir wissen doch eh schon, dass der Vater jetzt stirbt.
Das ist doch schon mal voll klar, oder?
Würde jemand mit was anderem rechnen?
Also, wer rechnet, dass der Vater überlebt?
Oder wer rechnet damit, dass der Vater jetzt gleich eine Löffel abgibt?
Er stirbt 100 pro.
Anderes geht nicht in dem Game.
Mikrolex?
Also, bei mir ist absolut null.
Ops, war nix.
0,0.
Für die Immersion.
Ich komm mir vor wie Torbjörn, ey.
Komm.
Wir haben die Gadgets, Papa.
Sie werden dich wegnehmen und dich locken.
Ich will nicht weg.
Ich verspreche dir.
Adel, du wirst jetzt stark für deine Schwester sein, okay?
Du hältst Mama hier und du hältst das klar.
So überleben wir.
Verstehst du?
Ja, Papa.
Hör auf.
Wenn wir draußen sind, bleibst du mit mir, okay?
Papa, Papa.
Ich bin hinter dir.
Hallo.
Was geht?
Oh.
Halt von...
Okay.
Ja, Papa.
Da hätte ich selbst drauf kommen können.
Wenn wir draußen sind, bleibst du mit mir, okay?
Ich heile.
Papa, Papa.
Wo heile ich?
Wo heile ich mich?
Hier.
Da heile ich mich jetzt.
Man kann doch nicht mal in den Schrank.
Ich heile mich in der Dusche.
Nein, ich soll mich heilen.
Ich kann nicht zuschauen.
Das ist Absicht, dass ich das nur höre.
Great hiding spots.
Welche Difficulty ist das normal?
Das haben sie spannend inszeniert, muss ich sagen.
Das ist ganz, ganz, ganz cool.
Wobei es halt null interaktiv ist.
Bisschen trainieren für später schon.
Someone there.
Ja, weil jetzt jeder auch rausläuft und sagt, ja, hier bin ich.
Kein Problem.
Geht's?
Ich hab keine Füße.
Wo sind...
Wo...
Ich bin unsichtbar.
Mich gibt's es nicht.
Find a weapon.
Ah, ich hab ein neues Objective.
Ich soll den Typ jetzt bashen von hinten.
Oh, voll ins Sack.
Moment, nochmal attacken.
Okay, big brain soldier.
Big brain.
Huge brain soldier.
Eindeutig.
Also...
Der ist...
Der ist absolut high IQ.
Ich mein...
Okay, so funktioniert's schon mal nicht.
Aber der ist schon bisschen...
Der ist schon bisschen blöd.
What?
Oh, ich habe...
Oh.
Where is the mother?
¨Hiding in hell¨
«Hiding in hell¨
Wow, komm her, jetzt werde ich dich bashen, damn, jetzt, komm her, ja, alter der Typ der
ist unglaublich dämlich, hallo, hallo, jetzt kommt Hadir und Bashtin, ich wusste es, ich
wusste es, das war so klar, Alter, jetzt übertreiben sie es aber, der hat doch was eingesteckt,
okay, das war ganz nice inszeniert, ich würde gerne auf die Waffe switchen, darf ich aber,
oh, das ist bestimmt lecker, das ist bestimmt lecker, jetzt in die Gasmaske reinzuschlüpfen,
nachdem da so ein verschwitzter russischer Soldat fünf Tage mit rumgelaufen ist,
der ist zu schwer, die konnten den Typ killen, aber er ist zu schwer, um die Waffe unter
ihm rauszuziehen, ernsthaft, kann sein Kopf,
nicht mitnehmen, wie soll ich sein Kopf mitnehmen, WTF, oh, er hat es überlebt, oh, es fängt
gleich das Haus an zu brennen, wir wussten es, der Vater überlebt es nicht, das war
so klar, ich meine, das ist jetzt ganz cool gemacht mit der Background Story, ja, aber
das Zeug vorher, das war so, auch so durchschaubar wieder, na, das, na, zum Glück ist es nur
mit der Waffe, das war so, das war so, das war so, das war so, das war so, das war so,
einer Schraube an der Tür, ein A-Tor, die hat Kraft, die Türöffnung abzubrechen, aber den
russischen Soldat mal kurz im Boden wegziehen, dass sie sich eine AK nehmen können, das hat nicht
funktioniert, wie Hadir übelsten Durchblick hat, ne, Hadir übelsten Durchblick gerade,
erst, er, erst noch irgendwie der Vater gestorben und jetzt schon so absolut Durchblick, wie man
sich da verhält.
5 head up. 5 head wide. Zumindest sind die Russen mal wieder die Bösen. Passt ja schon
mal zu Modern Warfare an sich. Drip, Huhn.
Wer hat eigentlich gesagt, dass hier auf logische Details geachtet wird? Keiner.
Haben sie ja offensichtlich auch nicht. Aber eine gewisse Logik macht die Sachen
in der Regel eigentlich nur besser. Letzte Zuckung. Das ist doch mal ganz
hübsch gemacht. Ohje, Leute, Leute seht ihr was das ist da drüben? Erkennt ihr was das
für eine Map ist da drüben? Seht ihr das? Seht ihr die Map da drüben? Seht ihr die Map? Das ist
Azir Cave. Das ist die Multiplayer Map. Die schlimmste Multiplayer Map im ganzen Game.
Das weiß ich aus der Beta. Das ist, wenn das nicht die schlimmste Multiplayer Map ist,
dann hat das Game komplett verloren. Das ist Azir Cave. Das ist eindeutig, das ist Azir
Cave. Ne, da hinten ist die Höhle und da vorne ist das Dorf. Ja, man kann leider nichts
mitnehmen. Ja, das ist Azir Cave. Eindeutig, das ist 1 zu 1 die Multiplayer Map. Nur mit
niedrigeren Details.
es ist nicht die schlimmste oje ich ahne schlimmes wenn die anderen noch schlimmer sind ich sehe es
gerade im vorfeld das bildet schon ein bisschen schlieren aber das kann nicht an der bitrate
oder so liegen 6.0 ist ziemlich gut das muss an den details wie rauch und lens flare und sowas
liegen dass der encoder ein bisschen probleme damit hat wir können mal was probieren total
für also ich sehe es näher sind ich sehe es in der vorschau also ich sehe es ja bei mir in der
vorschau also total verpixelt ist das nicht das sieht das sieht eigentlich ganz relativ normal
aus jetzt auch total verpixelt also ganz ehrlich 6700 bitrate encoding ist okay also da gibt es
jetzt nichts was ich da großartig machen kann ja ja ja sieht man doch hier 6900 habe ich
ich habe wir können mal was probieren wir können mal was probieren angenommen ich stelle es jetzt
stellt es jetzt mal stellt es mal ein mbit hoch mal gucken ob das on the fly geht
jetzt gucken wir mal ich habe jetzt jetzt mit noch mehr beträgt der standbild sieht immer gut aus
kann überhaupt nicht besser sein das ist jetzt ja auch standbild das pixel ich sehe es in der vorschau
um pixel das ist ja einfach hier nochmal wenig gehandelt des pixel ist beim encoder eyer
im real world ich habe eigentlich gesagt keine ahnung ich habe ja immer noch ein bisschen die
vermutung dass es am game liegt ich kann mir aber nicht vorstellen dass es am game kann wir probieren
jetzt mal was wir probieren was man gucken ich will mal gucken ob es nicht Ponzi mal die metre throwing der high res auf dem Person Phoenix.
mal was. Mal gucken. Ich will nur mal gucken, ob das
überhaupt geht mit noch mehr Bitrate.
Fuck, das geht echt mit noch mehr Bitrate.
Ich mein,
die Bitrate ist jetzt krass hoch, ja.
Ich seh jetzt das Pixel
mega krass im Himmel.
Ich hab,
ich hab keine Ahnung, woran das liegt.
Ehrlich nicht.
Tune. Film. Probieren mal
was.
Alter, das Pixel
mega.
Also Leute, kein Schimmer.
Ich hab echt keine Ahnung,
woran das liegt. Und
Modern Warfare ist auch das einzige
Game, wo das rumspackt.
Aber das ist halt,
das ist halt bei harten Farbübergängen,
da haben, da haben alle Encoder
Probleme mit.
Und das, ich, ich könnte wetten, dass es bei jedem,
der das Game streamt, ist das so.
Bei harten Farbübergängen.
Was mach ich da eigentlich gerade?
Oh, jetzt soll ich
ablenken, oder?
Dann ist es gebasht.
Checkt.
Oh.
Okay.
Fahrer hält nichts aus.
Okay, Fahrer kriegt, kriegt aufs Maul.
Das Pixel
echt ultra.
Leute, ich seh's bei mir in der Vorschau.
Ich hab keine Ahnung,
was das ist.
War das, war das mit Game Capture auch so?
Ich stell's mal hier weiter.
Da ist ja noch schlimmer.
Wisst ihr was? Wart mal.
Wir, wir, wir probieren mal was. Wir probieren was.
Ich zeig euch mal ein Gameplay von YouTube.
Das hat ja auch, äh,
bewegtes, an der Framerate,
kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Ähm, ich zeig euch jetzt mal ein Video, wo
sich auch, auch schnell, schnell bewegtes Gameplay
drin ist. Ihr Battlefield-Fazit.
Ach, Quatsch.
Ihr seht das ja gar nicht, ne?
Ah, ich hab jetzt falsche Display Capture an.
Pixelt da großartig was?
Ja, da pixelt auch was.
Das stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Doch, doch, klar, da pixelt auch was.
Das stimmt was nicht.
Also, irgendwas
spackt da bei OBS mit den Encoding-Settings.
Das ist definitiv
nicht richtig.
Das ist definitiv, ne, ne, ne, ne,
das ist definitiv nicht richtig.
E-Frame-Intervall?
Ich hab da überhaupt nichts dran eingestellt.
Ich mein, ich hab vorhin, doch, Leute,
das kann sein. Ich hab vorhin rumgestellt,
als ich auf
GPU-Encoding geswitcht hab.
Vielleicht,
ähm,
aber Null ist Auto.
Ähm, vielleicht
spackt das deswegen rum.
Ne, ne, ne.
Also, das ist definitiv
nicht richtig.
Das ist definitiv nicht richtig,
so wie das ausschaut.
Weil ich das OBS auch verbuggt. Ich soll mal die Version
updaten oder so.
So, weil ich hatte das die ganze Zeit
hier immer auf Very Fast stehen.
Okay, was machen wir dafür gescheite Settings?
14 hier.
Was, was, was kann ich denn bei, bei, ähm,
bei Profiles und so einstellen?
Das ist doch eigentlich ziemlich wurscht, oder?
Ja, das kann sein, dass die,
dass das mit Keyframe
rumspackt.
Da muss ich mal gucken. Also, ich,
Leute, ist noch jemand von ganz
von Anfang an da?
Am Anfang hat das nicht gepixelt. Am Anfang hatten wir
bloß Frametrops, oder?
Am Anfang hat das nicht gepixelt.
Am Anfang hatten wir bloß Frametrops, oder?
Anfang hat es nicht gepixelt, aber dafür hatten wir
Frametrops.
Und die Frametrops sind jetzt weg.
Ja, dann liegt das da dran, dass ich
das irgendwie auf Default Encoding
zurückgesetzt hat.
Und, ähm,
da muss ich mal gucken.
Da hatte ich garantiert irgendwas anderes eingestellt
hier. Vielleicht habe ich Glück
und habe in einem der letzten Streams mal zufällig
meine Settings gezeigt,
dass ich nachgucken könnte,
was ich hier eingestellt hatte.
Ne, ne, das reicht.
Very fast reicht. Das Pixel
liegt definitiv
irgendwo, irgendwo anders. Das liegt nicht
an der Bitrate, das liegt auch nicht an dem,
wie viel Zeit der Encoder, beziehungsweise wie viel
CPU der Encoder dafür, für einen Frame
braucht. Das ist, das ist auf jeden Fall
irgendein, irgendein anderes, anderes Problem.
Kann man vielleicht, wir probieren
mal was aus.
Ähm,
wenn ich das hier auf Simple stelle.
Start
ist mal neu.
Guck mal, es ist jetzt 21 Uhr,
ich könnte eh nur noch eine halbe Stunde
spielen. Ich glaube, ich bastel
da morgen früh mal und dann machen wir die Kampagne
morgen fertig.
Und schnappt ihr mal einen Bitrate-Rechner?
Hä? 8K?
Man kann,
Auflösung und FPS hat mit Bildrad
auch erstmal gar nichts zu tun.
Ich meine, es sieht halt einfach beschissener aus.
Umso mehr Bilder, umso mehr Pixel
du durchschleusen musst, umso schlechter
ist es bei der Bitrate.
Ähm, umso schlechter sieht es aus.
Vergleicher Bitrate.
Aber ich glaube, ich hatte
schon immer Constant Bitrate.
Und im Multiplayer kann ich auch immer
Spiele.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich irgendwo
in einem der letzten Streams meine OBS-Stats
gezeigt habe.
Wenn ich die gezeigt habe, dann...
Ja, meine OBS-Stats
waren ja gut.
Ähm...
Das ist bloß das Problem, dass ich die am Anfang
wegen den Frametrops
umgestellt habe. Das sagt...
Da muss ich mal suchen.
Naja, da würde ich sagen, Leute, wisst ihr was?
Wir spielen eigentlich morgen den Rest.
Das kann nicht mehr allzu lange dauern.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich irgendwie noch
eine Stunde oder so
spielen wir Kampagne.
Und dann spielen wir mal
ein bisschen Multiplayer.
Gucken wir mal, was Sache ist.
Also, Leute, wir sehen uns dann.
Macht's gut. Bis morgen.
See you.